Hello, hello, Ashley is- Dude, what the fuck?
This is the first- Alright, guys.
That is the first thing I read today for my playthrough.
What do you mean?
I am a good babysitter!
For those who don't know, I've told this story before a long time ago.
But, um, I actually- I took a- I did an after school club where we learned how to be babysitters.
I've never done it before.
Like, I never took this practice into, like, reality.
But, like-
But, I paid ten dollars for this after school activity.
Because after- after the whole duration of this activity that we did after school, um, we had to take a test.
And then get a, uh, a babysitter.
Certificate.
So, I have a babysitter certificate.
Which proves that I am- I can be a good babysitter.
I've never babysat before.
Afterwards.
Like, afterwards, I may have never babysat.
But- But I do have a certificate.
So, that makes me more qualified than anybody else here.
Do you have a babysitter certificate?
I don't think so.
I paid ten dollars for this.
Okay.
I have- I- I don't know where it is.
Because I took this after school activity in middle school.
So, like, I don't even know where the fuck the babysitting certificate is anymore.
Um, no, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's ten dollars for your expired certificate.
Um, Bacon, thank you.
Thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you, thank you.
Ashley's beautiful.
Excuse me.
I know that, like, Ashley is in good hands.
Okay?
I won't like it.
But, like, I wouldn't- She's literally the president's daughter.
Like, why the fuck would I- Like, why would you think that I cannot do it?
I am certified, guys.
Also, speaking of.
Our clips didn't win the best clip.
Guys, you guys lied to me.
So, you know about our deal.
Wait.
I just want you guys to know.
None of our Apex clips won the best clips in the Apex tournament.
Because, apparently, unlike me when I said, don't raid her chat to vote.
Apparently.
Other streamers were campaigning to- To their communities to vote for their clips.
So, like, the clips that won were- People were like, what the fuck?
Look, guys.
No, no, no.
It's good that we didn't raid.
Because now- Because- Because then people would be- Because people would say we rigged it.
Okay?
Now, we're not the ones that rigged it, guys.
It's good.
Because then other people would have said we rigged it.
They would be like, of course the VTuber rigged the- The- The clip awards.
But we didn't.
So, we're good people.
We didn't.
We have dignity.
Also.
We also- You guys also promised me something.
I was like, if these clips don't win.
I swear to fucking God.
We are the good guys.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They have no taste in clips.
Shake my head.
Mara, Doki needs to strut her babysitting skills for Ashley tonight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We have the moral high ground.
Because I said no- No rigging.
We lost though.
Because I forgot.
I forgot about- It's like student union.
I'm starting a student council all over again.
People- People will campaign.
It's 1000 dollars.
I forgot about that.
I forgot.
If it's a popular vote.
People would campaign for it.
I forgot.
Just like politics.
Anyway.
Alright, here we go.
You know, Resident Evil 4, I've always wanted to...
Well, I've always wanted to finish this game, but like, obviously...
I don't want to go back and play all the way to the beginning.
Because of the original game.
Because like, that was like, a lot.
Because that would require me to...
To deal with OG Ashley.
Who has one of the worst fucking NPC pathways ever.
So...
Because of my hatred of Ashley's NPC movements...
And escort missions...
I've decided to play the remake.
Because at least, I don't have to go through the original...
The original Ashley.
And instead, I can go through with remake Ashley.
Who apparently has better passing now.
So...
I decided...
For the sake of my sanity...
And not redoing the entire fucking 70% of the game...
I decided to do the remake.
Because at least, like...
It'll still be new to me.
And the pathing would not be as bad.
Like, I don't know.
I just feel like Ashley 2.0 was the way to go.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, adjust the pat...
Until the pat...
Where is the pattern?
Holy shit!
Why is it so bright automatically?
Okay.
Why is it like maxed out?
Um...
DDragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you hate Ashley in any Resident Evil 4, then it's a little skill issue.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I won't say I hate her.
I just...
I just don't want her to exist.
That's...
That's different.
Alright.
Let's see.
Adjust until the pattern is just barely visible.
Okay.
Then I guess...
This?
There we go.
Uh...
Here we go.
Adjust under...
Until the image in the center is barely visible.
If the image remains visible, please check your...
Okay.
Just until it is...
Barely...
Okay.
Oh my god.
If I make it so fucking bright, then like it won't be scary anymore.
I'm just saying.
If it's this bright, then like it's not a horror game.
It's just survival.
It's just action.
I can't be scared.
Because no monster is going to show up when it's bright.
Like that's typical horror.
Sassy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We all agree with you.
Nobody likes Ashley in OG Resident Evil 4.
Okay.
Let's see.
I think this is fine.
We'll just make it a little brighter.
Just a...
Just a little bit.
Defying the set.
Okay.
Nice.
Adjust the...
I think that's good?
Uh...
Let's see.
Why?
Okay.
I have to pretend to read it.
Uh...
Whoop.
I did it.
I do not consent.
Okay.
I do not have a Cap...
Do I have a Capcom ID?
If you do not have a Capcom that has been linked to the platform ID that you can check, please select I do not have a...
What the fuck is it?
Okay.
I should have read this.
Uh...
In the company's account service Capcom ID.
Why does every game have an account now?
Like...
Read the...
It's over.
She's not reading the terms of service.
Uh...
No!
Okay.
I'm going to...
Um...
All right.
Guys.
What is the Capcom ID?
Do I...
No idea but I hate it?
Okay.
I don't think I have one.
I'm just going to hide the screen just in case like it requires like personal information.
I'll just write.
I don't have one.
Your play data can be viewed on...
Why do I need my play data?
They will be sent to the REnet whenever you select quick game from the pause.
Why don't...
The game has an autosave feature.
Okay.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I'm going to...
Okay.
All right.
That's cool.
I love it when things don't matter.
All right.
So Capcom ID does not matter, guys.
That's what we learned.
All right.
Start game.
Ooh.
Loud.
A new extra game is available to download mercenaries.
Oh, but it's free.
No.
Do I need it?
I don't really care.
Wait.
Can I like buy skins for Leon online store?
Yes.
This is...
What the...
All right.
Cosmetics.
Let's see.
What the fuck is this bundle?
Oh my God.
Wait.
There is.
Leon and Ashley.
Okay.
Guys.
Do we need to be immersed?
I just need...
How much...
How much immersion do you guys want?
Like this is very important to how this game is going to be.
What do you mean by that?
I mean, I'm looking at the cosmetics right now.
This is a very important question.
Do you want immersion or...
Okay.
You guys want...
I won't buy anything then.
100.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
The nyanya clip is number one in my mind.
Yeah.
But it's not a winning clip.
All right.
All right, guys.
Fine.
We won't buy any of the...
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna buy all the Leon costumes.
There's literally one where...
Wait.
Is this one where he's like Baldur's Gate-esque?
There's one where you can see his chest.
Guys, it's tempting.
Guys.
I don't know.
Check out.
Guys.
There's a 25% off from the...
Come on!
Wait, is this like goth?
What the fuck?
There's a goth Ashley?
Okay guys, but there's like goth Ashley though.
Actually, you know what?
You know what?
I'm getting the goth Ashley.
We're getting that because no matter what, we don't really care about what Ashley looks like.
So might as well enjoy the ride.
Enjoy the ride of Ashley being goth.
It makes sense why she's like in this village.
Like she wanted to get away from the president.
Like her dad.
Alright, I won't make Leon immersive.
Because this other skin, he doesn't really look like Leon.
He's just like... it's just bald...
You know that vampire dude that everybody likes in Baldur's Gate?
Like he basically looks like this.
And like...
This might be a super hot take.
But I really don't care about that guy.
I don't really give a fuck about...
I don't even know his name.
So like...
I think it might be a super hot take.
Because like...
I swear everybody's obsessed over him.
I think it's the accent.
I honestly think it's not what he looks like.
It's literally like the accent.
It's always the accent.
Okay, I need to restart the game.
Alright, don't worry.
We're putting Goth Ashley in here.
Data, close the game please.
Zachary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Make this have all the cheese possible.
Alright guys, I am restarting this real fast guys.
Just to make sure...
Just to make sure we have what we want.
Alright, Resident Evil 4.
Alright.
I swear, it's mostly like...
It's like Tumblr guy.
He's the new Tumblr guy.
And there's always a pattern with Tumblr guys.
Like the sexy man Tumblr guys.
They usually have a British accent.
Alright.
Obtain costumes.
I already missed one.
Oh, gee.
Guys, I know there's people who did not like Ashley's newest costume.
Like the remake costume.
Don't pretend.
Here we go.
Alright, we're gonna make Ashley...
Oh my...
I like how this is casual Ashley.
Like this is what she wears casually.
Alright.
This is gonna be Ashley now.
Can I confirm this?
Alright, let's see.
How do I confirm that this is my Ashley?
This is...
Oh, I guess it's like scene... scene girl.
It's more like scene girl punk Ashley.
Alright, and then...
Can I confirm?
Can I confirm her?
Um...
Hahaha.
Alright, let's see.
I mean, it'll make me feel less bad about her like getting kidnapped.
Uh...
Wrong menu?
Wait, how do I...
How do I make her my Ashley?
This is my Ashley now.
I don't want to rescue...
Oh, when I start the game?
Okay.
You can now change...
Oh, here it is!
The Ashley fun.
Joy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, just remember.
Joy wanted this.
Joy wanted this, guys.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Yeah, this is...
My Ashley.
Oh, no.
Hot topic content.
Ashley's wardrobe.
Thank you for the super chat, JL.
Thank you.
This is...
This is our Ashley now.
Hahaha.
We all paid for this.
Ashley, default, please.
It's too late.
I paid money for this, Ashley.
Please, I beg you.
Guys, it'll make us feel bad when she dies.
Guys, we're...
There's a reason why I paid for this, Ashley.
So I feel less guilt.
Okay?
What the fuck is this jacket, though?
Okay.
Here we go.
We're fine.
Alright, new game.
I'm not doing hard- because this is survival and the thing I hate the most about survival horror is the ammo consumption.
So like, I've decided that like, I do not like trying to find ammo.
I really hate finding ammo.
I hate item management.
No, I've always told you guys.
I hate item management the most.
Out of difficulties.
What do you mean?
I hear the game perfectly fine.
They just chopped the guy's head off.
Where is the sound?
Okay, audio though, raise it up.
Thanks to the bio weapons created by Umbrella.
Somehow I made it out, but too many others weren't so lucky.
Oh no.
I was asked later to join a top secret government program.
Is that better now guys?
Not that I had a choice.
That's right.
You never have a choice.
Punishing missions nearly killed me.
At least I kept my mind off everything.
Sam, why aren't you buff?
You look like Captain America.
Pre-Captain America.
Hey, looks like a happy time Leon.
Don't worry.
Surely nothing bad is going to happen in a Resident Evil game.
That's not my Ashley.
But who the fuck is this girl?
Who is she?
Not my Ashley.
Oh wait, sound guy is here.
Sound guy, what do you think?
Maybe you did.
You have a strange sense of humor.
I'm going to let you in on a little secret.
Just between us.
A lot of people have gone missing around here.
And it's been that way for a while now.
Should be just another day in the office, right?
Hmm.
I mean last week there was a search for some missing hikers.
I'm sure you're- Missing hikers?
Look, the hikers are not important.
Are they the president's daughter?
I don't think so.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ashley is like worth 20 missing hikers.
The president's missing hiker.
The hiking guide.
Okay, hiking- The president's hiking guide is worth like half an Ashley.
The president needs to hike.
I'll boost it up a little.
Bro.
Are you watching him pee?
I can't get in there.
That's fucked up.
Oh.
Oh, bro.
Did you pee on a corpse?
Bro.
We are too- No, not me.
I looked away.
I respect a man's privacy if he needs to pee.
He sure is taking his time.
Did he fall in?
Better go and take a look.
Yes.
You, Leon.
You should go look instead of me.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Yes.
The guy that doesn't know this place.
You go on first.
I know.
He's in the forest.
Fall into what exactly?
Oh, wait.
I can move now.
Chapter one.
Ooh.
Okay.
You now change colored costumes and accessories in the extras.
All right.
Let's look at the sound.
The audio.
Okay.
Voice volume.
All right.
Voice is already boosted up.
Okay.
That's unfortunate.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
All right.
I'll lower like BGM and like sound effects and then boost up the regular volume a little bit more.
I don't know if sound guy is still up.
I don't know if sound guy is still here.
But I think that's gonna work.
Okay.
Graphics.
Uh, let's see.
Performance display.
I need to get... if there is motion blur, I need to get that shit off.
Uh, is there motion blur in this game, guys?
Okay.
Camera wobble.
God, no.
Turn the camera wobble for character movement.
No.
I hate that.
No camera.
Oh, okay.
Mouse sensitivity.
I'm gonna turn that.
Low already.
Uh, detail aim when aiming.
Okay.
Controls.
Is it in graphics?
Where?
Full HD performance.
Well, there's... that's it.
Oh, wait.
There it is.
Okay.
I just need to scroll.
Motion blur off.
All right, guys.
Sorry.
Technical stuff right now to make this a good experience for all of us.
Uh, shadow.
You know what?
We're fine.
Let's just hope our PC can handle this.
I swear to God.
I'm gonna go to the computer.
Oh, my God.
All right.
We should be good.
Did it save?
Oh, subtitle size.
Large.
Because we're blind as fuck.
Uh, I'm just gonna make sure everything's saved.
Motion blur off.
There we go.
Oh, is the FPS capped?
No, we don't need that.
Okay.
All right.
That's good.
Oh!
I don't like that.
I should...
I knew I should have fucking made this brighter.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Chapter one to watch a Doki bird.
I knew it.
I knew I should have made the fucking screen brighter.
Oh, this is way too dark.
I don't like this.
I don't fucking like this.
Ashley, where are you?
They really do.
I don't understand why they put motion blur in games.
Yeah, I'm reaching for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I guess it's for like console to hide.
I don't like the low frames and stuff, but like, that should be off on default.
Oh, hey, there's a deer.
Free food.
Oh, okay.
That's it.
All right.
I'll pack one for the ride.
Oh, crouch is E?
What the fuck is controller?
Okay.
What the fuck?
I need to know what is controller.
Control...
Command Ashley!
Okay, we're gonna put this as control and command Ashley is E.
Okay, I swear is there another control?
Toggle HUD.
What?
Okay, that's on the menu.
Okay.
Mayhem mode?
What?
What the fuck is mayhem mode?
Okay, I guess...
Well, I guess...
Apparently, this is very important.
So I guess... I guess we'll put this back to here because it conflicts with mayhem mode.
Whatever the fuck mayhem mode is.
Oh, it's mercenaries only?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay back to...
We're gonna change that back then because that's dumb.
I can't I cannot handle it.
I can't... Ashley does not deserve this at that point.
Ashley...
Ashley, you are not important enough for this.
Where is it?
Where... where the fuck is it?
Where's the... where's control Ashley?
Where are you?
Confirm menu reset.
Zoom mayhem mode.
Where the fuck did Ashley go?
I went past it.
Okay, Ashley control...
Command Ashley.
There you go.
Okay, you're gonna be E and then you're gonna be control because that is dumb as fuck.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Control E crouch stand and evade.
Evade?
You have been bound to the same action return without applying...
God, oh God!
Can I just get rid of this?
Oh, shit.
Oh shit.
Uh... delete.
...
Where is my delete button?
Fuck!
Okay, I need to grab my other keyboard!
I apparently don't have a delete button on my fucking 60%.
Do I have a delete button on this one?
Where the fuck is delete?ูุง Alright!
Where's my other keyboard?
I don't have a delete button on this keyboard too?
This is a mess.
Okay.
It's a... guys I don't have a delete...
Guys!
I don't have a keyboard that has a delete button!
This is so bad!
Okay, this is awkward.
We'll just make this E.
That should be fine.
Alright, good.
You guys are smart.
This is why I have you guys here.
You can make decisions for me.
Alright.
We should be fine.
Good.
Okay, now we can crouch.
Oh, thank god.
We're figuring this out together.
Alright.
Knock knock!
Hello?
Are you in here?
Police officer?
Were you trying to find the toilet?
Even though we saw you pee outside?
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh!
I do not like this at all.
Yay.
Ummm...
We'll just go through the first door.
Hello, sorry for barging in.
But I'm a cop.
Is there anything I can steal?
I mean, not steal.
Borrow.
What's this?
Judgment is nigh.
Crude charm.
Okay.
Obtain file.
Don't worry.
A cop would never steal.
We're here to borrow.
We'll return things eventually.
That's what the taxpayers money is for!
We'll pay you back with your own taxes!
Oh...
When the time...
Never mind.
I do miss OG.
I miss OG Resident Evil now.
I wish this was the OG Resident Evil 4.
This was less scary back in the original.
The graphics made it silly.
Oh!
Bro, are you okay?
Sorry to barge in like this.
Bro, you okay, sir?
Those eyes don't look healthy.
What are you doing in your own house?
Wait, that's him.
That's Mario.
That's Mario!
Sir!
What are you doing in your own house?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Self-defense.
They can't arrest me.
It's self-defense.
It's not my fault.
It's not my fault, guys.
He attacked me in his own house.
So I...
And...
It's self-defense.
Even though it's his house.
Just remember.
Okay, can I keep this?
Ooh.
Is that cat?
What the fuck?
Okay, we have a key here.
Oh, we can't go this way anymore.
Wait, did he lock the door?
Just let me move.
Move the fucking wood.
Oh wait, no.
This is the door.
Whoops.
Oh, why did this get scarier?
Hello.
Oh no.
This is a cult.
Ooh.
Sensitivity is way too low.
Let me move up the sense a little bit higher.
Where's the sense?
When aiming.
Okay.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay, nevermind.
This was better.
The original.
They knew what I liked.
Alright.
Hello?
Ooh.
Rats.
Where's the guy that he killed?
Hello?
This is not a home invasion.
I have my rights.
MicroDrive.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Breaking news.
VTuber Tomato Doki Berry breaks into house and kills...
No!
Self-defense!
I legally entered his home!
I read you.
What's your situation?
Leon, I don't think he's okay.
I don't know.
That sounded... He sounded very scared.
That sounded...
He sounded very scared.
Oh no.
Escape from the hunter's lodge.
Okay.
Oh, I can shoot now.
Oh, I don't like this.
Okay.
If I have my gun now, I'll be ready for anything.
Hello?
I'm legally allowed to shoot you if you scare me.
Oh!
No fucking way.
How do you headshot if he has no head...
If his head is already...
What?
How do you headshot if his head is already off?
Oh no.
How do I...
How do I knife?
Okay.
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
Okay, space bar.
Space bar is knife when they get too close.
When they get too close.
Space bar is knife.
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
Okay, there you go.
I just need to get my reflexes going on here.
Okay.
Alright.
There's a guy right there.
Maybe he's gonna walk back.
Sir?
Are you gonna walk back?
Can you walk back so I have a longer...
So I don't have to turn around?
Oh no.
Fuck.
Okay.
Sir!
Please!
Please walk back!
Do I go up?
Guess I go up.
I don't know.
Maybe there's stuff up here.
I know this is not...
considered getting out, but maybe there's...
stuff here.
What the fuck?
What's this?
Also, how's the volume so far?
Yeah, escape by going up.
Okay, so it makes sense.
This is Gondor One.
Hunnigan here.
What's your sitrep?
President's daughter, Baby Eagle.
It's likely she's in this village.
Our intel was correct then.
Well done.
Need a location on a nearby lake.
She may have been taken there.
Copy that.
I'll see what I can find.
Where is the president's daughter?
Please!
Dad wants to apologize for saying it's a phase!
Oh no.
How does this game get harder now?
Oh, that is way too many people!
Oh, thank god!
I don't have to shoot them.
Okay, I'm out of the house.
Now they have no legal rights to kill me.
Because I'm not doing a home invasion anymore.
I have my rights.
I'm not in this house anymore.
So now, the only thing I can do is...
They can't kill me!
Because I'm not breaking any rules!
I'm not trespassing!
Exactly!
I'm not trespassing anymore.
Alright.
I'm so scared.
I'm getting so scared.
Okay.
Hello?
Is anybody here?
Does anyone have spirit?
Do you have your ammo?
Ooh!
Ask and you shall receive.
Nice.
I knew it!
I knew somebody kept ammo somewhere.
You win this time!
Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god!
They painted it yellow!
For stupid people like me!
You guys didn't know.
Early on in game testers...
People wouldn't do anything with the barrels...
until you painted it yellow.
And then people realized... wow!
Wow!
Yellow means I can break it!
We can customize my case?
Aww!
I only have one case.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
My knife is like...
so fucked up though.
Can we use to craft ammo?
Okay, craft.
I don't have enough.
Okay.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Freedom America!
Woo!
Baby!
Super chat sent by a real American.
Real.
Okay.
Wait.
Did I just go backwards?
I did.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Save 10 bucks each time my dumb ass co-worker said something stupid out of pocket.
Decide part of it should go to the best tomato round.
Thanks for everything.
Thank you.
Thank you for the acasupa.
I really appreciate it.
I hear some angry Spanish to my right.
Should I go left?
No!
Dog!
That's a waste of good food.
I don't think I want to go to the right right now.
I'm scared.
Oh, more ammo.
Nice.
More ammo for me to whiff.
Okay.
Crouch.
Nice.
Thank god.
Oh.
Hello?
Anybody?
I will shoot!
Wait.
Yes!
I did say I would shoot!
Give me a sec!
I said I would shoot!
I said self-defense!
Here we go.
Wait.
What?
Wait a minute.
He's not dying.
He's not dying!
What is this?
Okay.
That is a waste of ammo.
So when they are human...
When they are human...
I shoot the head!
And then when they become...
Whatever the fuck that was...
I shoot the knees.
Okay.
That's good.
Ice skating style.
You understand that reference?
I don't even know if I can say that.
I'm not...
Thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Okay.
What the fuck?
No!
Okay.
I was like right in front of it for so long.
Not to look at bear trap.
Bear trap?
Okay.
I hate this.
Alright.
I need to heal.
Okay.
Flash grenades.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
You can set your weapon to a shortcut.
Good thing we don't have anything else right now.
Her... Her gun... It cannot be used by itself.
Well.
Do I heal?
What's my HP?
How fucked am I?
Okay guys.
What is my HP right now?
I can't tell.
Oh there it is.
I'm half HP.
It's okay Leon.
If you're half HP you can survive.
American healthcare is still very expensive.
We gotta give you...
We gotta give you medicine when you're just about to die.
Alright.
Okay.
Knock knock.
Hello?
Don't worry.
The fuck is that?
A head?
Oh that is a head.
Don't worry.
The spray bottles can heal a broken leg.
Oh.
Remember when I like...
was so fucking stupid and killed everybody?
In this town?
I wasn't supposed to kill everybody?
Alright.
And wasted all that ammo?
We can do that again.
It would.
It wouldn't hurt to do that again right?
Hello.
Okay.
There is the police officer.
Oh shit.
That sucks bro.
That fucking sucks.
Wait can I put him out of his misery?
Don't worry!
I'll put you- oh he's dead.
Sorry I was a bit too late.
Sorry.
I could- sorry I watched a little bit too long.
I could have shot you first before all of that.
Alright.
There was an attempt.
Yes.
I don't know.
Maybe I should just kill them all.
You know what guys?
I think I can kill all of them.
Guys?
No I have ten bullets.
Nevermind.
I just realized how much ammo I have.
Um.
Shit.
Okay.
Can I just run back?
Alright here we go.
Sneak around first?
Guys do you think they will see me if I just walk like this?
Nah.
Oh wait.
No they won't.
Oh my gosh you're right.
Wait what's this?
Oh that requires Ashley.
Wait there's grass here.
I'll get my grass real fast.
This.
They won't know.
Wait.
There she is.
Hello there granny.
I'm here to take you to a better home.
You'll be okay.
Don't worry.
You're just going to go to a farm downstate.
She's okay.
It was a tranquilizer.
She's okay it was a tranquilizer guys.
What do I do here?
Where the fuck are people here?
A very long tranquilizer.
Oh.
Where the fuck do I go from here?
Okay give me a sec.
I need to figure this out.
Oh I can combine.
Craft.
Mix herb.
What does this do?
Restore three times as much health.
Oh okay.
Now where do I go?
Follow the path.
What path?
That?
Is that a path?
Okay.
There's no way he sees me.
There's no fucking...
No you don't see me!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh I fucked up guys!
I fucked up!
Oh!
Is that a door?
Oh fuck!
Wrong door!
Guys!
That was the wrong door!
Oh shit!
Don't wait!
Oh!
Don't worry!
Wrong door!
It's okay!
Apparently I don't have a stamina meter!
We've learned!
Okay.
There we go.
Wrong door!
I'll just keep running backwards!
We've learned how to do this!
I ran to the dead end!
Nothing has changed.
Nothing has changed for me!
Oh god!
It's okay!
Nothing has changed!
My knife is stronger!
Leon please!
You're so strong Leon!
That's great!
Go!
Nothing has changed for me!
Okay!
Alright!
Let's go get some heals real fast!
It's just like old times!
Okay.
Oh please don't tell me he's over here.
Oh my god!
Hey guys!
Oh fuck!
Bye guys!
Okay it's fine!
It's fine!
I'm reloading!
It's just like old times!
Never forget!
Woo!
But I couldn't make it in time!
Okay.
Woo!
What the fuck are you doing here?
Don't worry.
I can run.
I cannot run around but I can run down here.
Don't worry!
Kick!
Oh please leave me alone!
Oh!
Kick!
Woo!
Shit!
Okay!
Oh!
Guys!
Okay it's fine!
Three bullets and a dream!
It's okay!
I have a friend!
Alright!
Nothing has changed!
If you close your eyes!
Ba da da da!
Ba ma!
Ba ba ba ba ba dum!
If you close your eyes!
Woo!
Thank you!
Just keep running!
What?
Shit!
Okay!
Just keep running!
Don't kill the friends!
Oh my god!
Granny please!
Woo!
Seraphine!
I ran out of ammo!
Unlike last time!
I don't remember where all the ammo is!
Oh!
My knife is broken too!
Okay!
It's fine!
I know!
There's a... I'll get it when everybody's dead!
Guys!
I'll grab the shotgun when people are dead!
But at the moment!
We don't have that!
Ah!
Shit!
It's okay!
She missed!
Wee!
It's just run!
Guys!
I don't have the mental portent to grab the shotgun right now!
I don't know where it is!
It's totally fine!
There's so many houses!
Which is the right house?
Oh!
Thank god!
Okay!
I did it!
Now I can go through the houses!
Oh!
I survived!
I did it!
Carl!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Here lies Doki!
Her knife broke and she ran out of bullets!
Here we go!
First try!
Say the line Leon!
Say the line!
Leon!
Where's everyone going?
Bingo?
Wooo!
He said the line!
Resident Evil 4!
Holy fuck!
We did it!
Alright!
Let's go find out how to get the axe!
Or the shotgun!
Please stop talking to me!
I need to get the fucking shotgun!
Windmill!
Copy that!
And be careful!
First out!
Copy and ninja!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay!
Let's go grab some ammo!
Alright!
Oh!
Nice!
We can craft stuff here!
He set the thing guys!
He did it!
Can I open this?
Okay!
Oh!
That...
I mean!
Good thing I didn't find it!
I didn't find these guys!
Or I would have wasted it all on this mission!
Guys!
Just remember!
I could have wasted that!
If I found all these items!
Instead of...
It's a good thing I wasted my inferior regular handgun bullets!
Instead of my...
Instead of my shotgun ammo!
I'm big braining it guys!
This is all...
This is all big brain!
Okay!
Where the fuck is the...
Shotgun at?
Shotgun?
I'm so confused!
I'm already lost!
What is that?
What is this?
Oh!
Gap in the wall!
Where?
Yeah!
It's all part of the plan!
Guys!
I would have wasted it!
I would have wasted my...
My shotgun ammo!
On something inferior!
Okay!
That nice handgun ammo!
We needed that!
Where the fuck could the...
That?
Over there?
Now I vault over this?
Nice!
I can't...
Oh shit!
There's stuff here!
From all the people I killed!
Money!
Mius!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
He said the thing!
Chainsaw guy would have...
Yeah!
But no...
But no... I was never gonna kill him!
There was no way!
Is it... Okay!
I don't know if you guys think I will actually remember the layout!
I like how you guys think I remember this layout!
It's been two years!
There's a key... here.
Oh shit!
Okay!
Alright!
Nice!
Okay!
He just gave me five bullets!
I mean...
Five hundred dollars!
That's alright!
Surprise!
Where the fuck could...
Yeah!
I can't believe it!
He's not praying!
What the fuck is he doing?
How...
How did he...
What the... Where am I?
How dare he!
Oh my god!
The church is not gonna like this!
Found a man not praying!
Oh nice!
First aid spray!
I missed a yellow barrel!
Is it back there?
Guys!
It just wasn't yellow enough I guess!
Where I killed him?
Oh he's... Oh there it is!
Boop!
Nice!
Money!
Alright!
Off I go!
Okay!
Thank god Ashley is still not here!
I don't... I don't think how it would have gone very well!
I like... I'm just getting PTSD of the Ashley missions!
Oh there's the shotgun!
Nice!
Okay!
Oh nice!
And then...
I'm gonna steal...
I'm gonna borrow this real quick!
And then...
Oh what's this?
Nice shotgun ammo!
Okay!
Can I jump out?
Oh now you don't wanna jump out the window!
Oh okay!
Oh is there items here?
Could be anything here?
Any items?
Any loot?
Am I done looting?
I can't tell!
I'm already lost!
Not that one!
Why can't he pick and choose what window?
This is life or death!
It shouldn't matter!
I got here?
Yeah I did!
Did I loot everything?
I can't tell I'm so fucking lost!
I can't tell!
Everything looks the same to me!
Okay this is just an empty area.
Anything here?
Oh!
Herb!
Left my grass!
Shoot the chicken?
Does the chicken give me loot?
Chicken do you give me loot?
Guys that was a perfectly good bullet!
I can't believe it!
Guys!
This is exact...
Thank fucking god I'm not playing on hard mode!
That would've been my last bullet!
Wait what's this?
Oh it's a locked drawer!
Knowing you guys!
That would 100% been my last bullet!
If I was on hardcore mode!
I missed the ammo right here.
Alright there is a...
Oh there it is!
Nice!
Thank fucking god!
Oh!
Let's see.
Alright let's see...
The ladder here!
Wait what's the ladder for?
Oh my god that's a ladder!
I didn't even realize that was a ladder.
I thought it was just interior.
Herb!
I'll need this...
AHH!!
I don't have a knife!
I broke it!
What do you mean!
You have a knife.
Deadpool!
I broke my knife!
Go back to the chicken and pull the bullet out.
Because I don't know if you guys know how guns work.
But I'm pretty sure that's not how guns work.
What's in here?
Oh, ruby!
That's right.
Your family heirloom is mine now.
There's also a house here.
Nice.
More ammo.
Doki, you don't understand.
If you throw it really, really hard...
Maybe it'll pierce that guy's skin.
Open!
I swear.
I need to be careful of bear traps now.
Knowing me, I might step into all of it.
Wait, what?
That house?
You mean there it is?
Here?
That far?
I already miss OG.
I already miss OG Resident Evil 4.
It was definitely a lot less scarier.
It was campier.
Which meant I wasn't as scared.
When can I customize my case?
If I craft two greens...
That's twice as much.
Then...
Might as well make more shotgun ammo.
Yeah, shotgun shells.
Time to play Tetris.
No, no, don't discard it.
I honestly would not be surprised if I accidentally discard this.
Okay, let me save again.
Friend, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
You got this.
I believe you.
For the bloodline, Doki.
For the bloodline!
Think about the bloodline, Leon!
Chicken.
Is that fresh water?
Oh, there's a cow!
Shoot.
Ask questions later.
Oh, he has two headshots.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
We're fine.
Oh, hello, lady!
I remember you...
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
Lady, lady, lady!
Give me a sec!
Okay, there you go.
Give me a sec.
I'm charging up my gun!
There we go.
Oh, fuck!
Um...
Nice.
Cow just chill?
No, that cow's dead.
Wait, there...
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, you have eggs?
What the fuck?
What am I gonna do with an egg?
Can be used...
Oh my god!
You wanted me to kill the chickens?
They give you unlimited heals!
They have eggs!
Brown chicken egg?
Is that better?
Oh my god!
The brown chicken eggs are better!
Ow.
Did that chicken fucking hit me?
Okay, maybe I'll kill this chi...
It's... Oh, it's a male.
I can kill this chicken.
It's a rooster.
He wasn't gonna be providing any eggs.
It's okay, guys!
It was a male rooster!
Let's see...
I need to make sure... Okay, farm here...
No, no...
Freddy, thank you for that 50 gift of chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Wait, the pig... Okay.
To be fair, pigs are carnivores, though.
They like...
They eat anything.
Like, that's what they say.
People say like if you just like throw a body at a pig, like it's like one of the best ways to like hide the bodies because they'll just eat the body.
That's why like pigs can even eat their own cows.
If they like... If the pigs got cut or something, the pigs will smell the blood and will be like, ooh!
Yeah, pigs eat everything.
Will I ever use the grenades?
Let's see...
Well, to be fair, any animal eats their own babies.
It's not just pigs.
That's a dead point!
Thank you for the five gift of chips!
Thank you, thank you!
It's not like a pig thing.
Every animal eats their own babies because it's like survival of the fittest.
So if they think a baby is not worth like taking care of, they'll just eat it because they're like it's not worth it.
Okay, I need a key for that.
Because they're like, I'm not gonna take care of this baby.
That's too many babies.
So then they'll just eat it to like...
What the fuck?
I heard somebody.
Who said that?
Hello?
Where are you?
Are you trying to open a door?
Where is she?
That her?
I hear you.
She's inside.
Hello?
Oh, ma'am, there you are!
Where did you come from?
Can you get a little bit closer?
Thank you.
Thank you, that's a lot easier.
Can you get a little bit closer?
There we go.
Can you turn around?
Alright, here you go.
Nice.
Where did she come from?
Wait, where did she come from?
There's no entrances here.
Hello?
Where did you come from?
Alright, time to open the door.
Boop.
No good.
Oh.
How the fuck did she get there?
Medallion?
Where's the medallion?
I already walked, looked through everything.
Where did she come from?
Where did she go?
The chickens?
Watch the chickens?
What do you mean?
They seem like...
They seem like good chickens.
What do you mean?
Oh, you mean this thing?
This thing?
Do I shoot this?
I forgot if I shoot this.
Oh, I do.
Okay.
I remember now.
Oh, there's another one.
Right here.
What a waste of perfectly good bullets though.
There you go.
Two.
Wait, what happens if I find all five?
This is new.
I don't know.
Or maybe it's not.
I never was an achievement hunter.
Maybe it wasn't new.
I just don't ever realize.
It's worth it.
If only I have a knife.
I know!
If only the chainsaw guy didn't fucking fuck me up.
Oh, there's one.
Where's the last two?
Are all of them in this village?
Wait, they're on the map too?
They are?
Liar!
Hahaha!
What the fuck do you mean?
The blue paper?
Wait, is the blue paper considered?
You can take on tasks by collecting the blue request notes.
View the requests you've taken.
The love of god with some, please get rid of blue medallions.
Those religious lunatics left hanging around.
Rewards.
Finale 3.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
What the fuck is a spinel?
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I should have taken the blue paper first.
Wait, how do I get that?
I can't even get there.
Oh!
Okay, that other one I can get to easily.
That one's here.
That's...
Wow!
Chicken!
Okay, now I know why people said watch out for the chickens.
Medallion here?
Okay.
Where?
I don't see any blues.
Where the fuck is that blue?
What?
Oh, gamers don't look up.
Oh my god.
Of course.
Always.
It's always up.
Okay, how do I get there though?
I think I need a key.
Blues clues.
Fucking wacky ass blues clues shit.
Like, how do I?
I can't open this door.
From the window?
Can't get up.
How do I get up there?
Windmill?
There's a windmill?
Here?
Oh, there is!
Hello?
Oh, that's a bomb.
Okay.
Can I just?
Okay, I'm just gonna walk under it.
Wait, can I disable it?
Oh, I can!
Nice.
Okay, thank god.
I almost thought that was gonna fuck me over.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Grab this yellow herb.
Hello?
Anybody up top?
I feel like there's somebody up top.
There's always somebody up top.
I'm coming up, guys!
I'm gonna announce my... I'm gonna announce my appearance!
Oh, what's this?
A puzzle?
God, what happened to the repair people here?
My god!
If I was an inspector...
If I was an inspector, I would close all of this down.
There you go.
Five.
I did it!
Where's my spinel?
Okay, red herb handgun.
Nice.
Can I go through here?
Nice!
Free loot!
Wait a minute.
Hello?
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Who the fuck is that?
Who's that?
Who's he?
Okay,
I'll just shoot you in the head now!
Oh, it's you!
I'm sorry!
I'm trespassing again!
Oh, shit.
Please don't climb up the ladder.
Please.
Please, I'm reloading.
Okay, thank god.
Here we go.
We're good.
It's fine.
Are you guys dead?
Oh, I don't have a knife.
I'm just gonna shoot you in the legs then.
Alright, here you go.
I have to shoot you in the legs because I don't have a knife.
Are you dead?
He's dead.
Oh, thank god for ladders!
Thank god!
Saved by the ladder!
Nice.
We did it.
Oh, thank god!
A kitchen knife!
That would have been so helpful earlier.
Oh, nice ruby too.
Alright, we did it.
We got the...
Saved by ladders.
I love it.
You won because the ladder buffed.
I wish I could have taken that guy's fucking hammer though!
The hammer seemed pretty fucking neat!
Alright, what the...
Okay, cannot be used.
I combine the hands of your...
You know, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna come craft.
I'll mix the red and the yellow.
What does it do?
It'll increase my maximum...
Oh, wait!
That's good!
Should I just eat it now?
Or the throwing axe, yeah.
Red, yellow, green.
I'm not gonna throw it.
I might as well just eat it now.
I don't need the heals at the moment.
Yeah, but I don't need the full heal.
I feel like that's a waste.
I might as well just heal this.
Get this.
Wait when you...
Fine!
I'll wait until I...
Fine, I'll combine it with the green.
Fine.
Okay.
Tetris.
Nice.
God, for the fucking high ground shit though.
Did I get the thing automatically?
Where's my... whatever the fuck that was?
Here.
Can I claim it?
I destroyed it all.
Does it automatically go to me?
I'm confused.
Confused doki right now.
Oh, at the merchant!
Okay.
I have to visit him.
Is the merchant the only sane person in this village?
Why doesn't Leon take the weapons?
Is he stupid?
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
A knife made for cooking its edge.
Alright, well, this is apparently my knife now.
Well, can I fix this?
I guess like I have to send it to the merchant to fix it.
What is this?
For selling only.
2000.
What the fuck?
The ruby is more expensive.
Wait, actually...
I don't know.
Wait, there's like a place I haven't gone here.
Alright.
Yeah, my fucking kitchen knife.
Be...
Be scared.
I have a kitchen knife now.
Woooo.
Nice money.
Open?
Is that the...
What?
What is this?
Oh, it's a...
You're buying treasures, you can view the treasures.
Some treasures are going to be sold by fitting them.
What the fuck is this?
OK.
I just put...
Can I make this more expensive?
If I put two rubies, do I make this more expensive?
Oh.
Oh!
Now, ruby number two.
Two!
Okay.
Ruby number two.
Oh, plus 3000!
Wait, but like, it's already... wait.
But if I sell it, it's already 3000.
Like, what?
Okay, two gems.
Oh, one times two!
I feel like I might as well... it gives you a bonus.
Well, I can only combine two right now, so I might as well just combine the double.
Oh!
Quick maths.
Barrels.
I want all this money.
Come on.
Yes.
Okay.
Wait, can I kick this too?
No lock can contain these thighs!
Neil, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm not sure if merchant even is.
I'm just one person, considering his magical...
That's just his twin brother.
Or triplets.
Or like, I don't know, he just... comes from a very big family!
You don't understand!
It's like Nurse Joy's!
The Nurse Joy's and Officer Jenny's...
They're all just like one big, giant family.
They're like the merchant family.
Alright.
I'm gonna save my game.
I don't trust myself.
Get out of the way, pigs.
I'm gonna save my game.
I'm gonna save my game and use the bathroom real quick.
Wait, where's... it's over here.
Where it all started.
I'll be right back guys.
I saved the game.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back guys.
It's okay.
We saved our game.
Nothing bad is gonna happen to us now.
That's how it goes.
Alright, up I go.
There we go.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot where I was.
I didn't show you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Irene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the super.
Irene.
Oh no, not here.
Bro, not the chainsaw man.
Do I have shotgun M?
Okay, three.
Let me...
Let me reload real quick.
Alright.
Here we go.
I remember this place.
Deja vu.
What's this?
Can I push this?
Do I push this now or later?
Oh, maybe this isn't.
Is this it?
Is this the place?
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
I have the grenades too.
Don't worry.
I'm very prepared this time.
Wait, what?
What's over here?
Maybe there's something here.
Jesus Christ, Leon.
These fucking thighs.
I'm worried.
I'm always worried.
Shredding off the path now.
I feel like anything's gonna get me.
Leon's never skipped leg day.
Alright.
Do I have to go up here?
I mean, I could just go this way.
What if I don't go up to that house?
I could just go this way instead.
I mean, it wouldn't hurt.
Nothing can hurt me if I go this way.
I'm gonna go this way.
Even if Ashley is over there, maybe it won't matter.
Maybe it won't matter.
Hello?
Oh, it doesn't matter anyway.
I couldn't fucking open the door.
What the fuck, guys?
It doesn't matter.
I couldn't even open the door.
Alright.
It's fine.
It was not...
It was not even loot anyway.
There wasn't even loot there.
Liars!
The illusion of choice.
Okay, are there any fucking traps?
No traps.
Okay.
Thank god.
Oh my god!
My thighs!
Those thighs saved me yet again!
Good job, Leon!
Uh oh...
The double illusion of choice.
I love the double illusion of choice...
... out there.
Let's see.
Nice money!
The power of thighs saved me yet again.
Save me yet again!
I knew you had it in you, Leon...
Those thighs will never...
Oops, still locked.
What the fuck?
Where do I go then?
Where do I go?
Do I go back on the back?
Maybe do I drop down from here?
No?
Was it the right way?
Oh, they didn't block the path?
Oh my god, I thought they blocked it!
I just thought it was blocked!
Okay, let me go back then.
Oh no!
Fucking rocks fell down!
I didn't know Leon could climb!
I mean, he couldn't fucking climb before!
Oh, it was just logs.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh, oh!
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
That's not cool.
Guys, I can shoot through this, right?
Oh, I can.
Grab the needle.
I love cheese!
Okay, where's the other guy?
Where is the other guy?
Wait, where is the other guy?
Oh, he's over here.
Okay.
I love cheese.
Wait.
I killed them.
There's loot over there.
I killed them though.
Right.
I'm up here?
Why is the tree shooting?
Oh!
Sorry.
Gamers don't look anywhere but straight.
Nice.
So easy.
Okay, can the granny get a little bit closer?
Granny, I need you to get closer so I can hit the head.
Thank you, granny.
Granny, can you run a little bit closer?
Granny, you're just...
You're almost there, granny.
So I don't have to run too far.
Okay, there you go.
Thank you, granny.
It saves...
Look, these thighs...
These thighs need to break right now.
These thighs need a break.
I need her to get closer so I don't have to run too much for loot.
And I need to make sure I don't fucking step on bear traps too.
I feel like Doki's gonna grenade herself instead of...
Yes.
100%.
That should not even be a question.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, there has to be like maintenance on these thighs.
You can't like overuse it.
Where the fuck is my flashlight?
How do I ping my flashlight to be used?
It is clearly dark, Leon!
Turn on your flashlight!
Okay.
Oh, hello.
F?
It's not F.
I tried.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello?
Hello, guys.
Oh, there's granny.
Who are they?
Try that.
No!
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Wait, where is he?
Oh my gosh, where are they?
I hear the bomb!
Oh, okay.
Okay, he blew himself up.
Okay.
It's like, I hear it.
Hello?
I know granny is over here.
Granny?
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
Hello?
What?
That's a hit!
There we go.
Oh, no.
Died?
That's five.
Oh, many!
Nice!
Big thighs!
Save lives.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
Big thighs!
Oh!
No!
Okay.
I'm just gonna deal with this gap first.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Gotta reload.
Oh, give me a sec.
Whoa!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God!
Okay, that's good.
That is good.
Oh!
There are more!
God, shit!
Oh!
Ho!
Don't hurt me.
I'm in my suitcase.
Do not hurt me!
Oh, God.
Okay, thank you.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Wait, what?
Where did she throw that?
Where is she?
Time out!
Ma'am?
Ma'am!
Where are you?
Where is she?
Where is the invisible granny?
Ma'am!
I don't like this.
I don't know where the invisible granny is.
Is she up there?
Grandma!
Please!
Come down!
I won't hurt you!
I'm just gonna take you to a farm downstate!
I swear!
Granny, please come down!
Your family's worried about you!
This is a tranquilizer gun!
There we go.
I hope she's not gonna turn.
Is she gonna morb?
No, she's fine.
I just need her head to poke up for like one second.
There we go.
Oh no, she's fucking turning.
Shit!
Jesus Christ!
Please!
Granny!
I have the power!
It's alright.
I'm just gonna wait a little bit.
There we go.
Okay, is she gonna...
NO!
I hate these bear traps so much.
God damn it, these stupid fucking bear traps.
How do I, okay.
How do I disable this?
I see you.
I acknowledge your existence.
How do I disable?
I acknowledge it's a- oh knife, okay.
Okay.
What do I do?
Why?
Oh!
Oh thank god, I thought I like stepped on it.
Oh thank fucking god.
I honestly thought I just stepped on it.
Oh thank god.
Alright.
Thank god I didn't step on it guys, there's hope.
Wait how do I...
How do I get in?
Oh.
I hear something here.
Oh there's a crystal.
What is that?
What is that sound?
I don't like this.
What the fuck is that sound?
A collectible?
Oh it's above me!
I see it!
How do I get it?
Do I just shoot it?
Oh I do.
Okay.
Alright.
I do.
Alright that will be the only collectible I get in this entire run.
Alright.
That should be...
I swear to god if there's another fucking bear trap...
I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Uhhhh...
Just making sure I didn't miss anything.
Alright, we can go this way then.
Did we miss anything?
No we didn't.
Alright.
Reload.
Reloading.
Wait there's more?
Oh there is more.
Sir.
Please.
Get away.
Oh no.
I have to... Oh no he's...
Okay he's not... He didn't... He didn't turn.
Oh thank god.
I thought I had to like fucking knife... knife him with my kitchen knife.
I didn't have to...
Oh it's... Hey guys remember this?
Hahaha.
Wait before I shoot the lake...
Is there a save point anywhere?
Is there a save point?
Guys!
Please tell me I don't have to restart my entire game!
Oh this is the wrong... Oh thank god.
This is the wrong part of the lake.
Okay we're just gonna admire the scenery.
Alright that's... Thank god.
Okay.
Okay that's good.
That's good.
It's the wrong part of the lake.
I hear people inside.
Can I go over here?
No.
Can't.
There's people inside though.
I'm ready.
I reloaded my gun.
I'm ready to shoot whoever is in there.
Self defense.
I swear to god if there's a bear trap.
Okay.
Oh I don't like this.
Oh.
Which way do I go?
Hello?
Oh.
Don't like that.
Oh somebody's inside there.
That's very angy.
Hello?
There's a la...
Yeah I know but like...
I wanna know like...
If I could go inside...
Oh there it is.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god.
Please Leon.
Leon please.
Leon.
Please Leon.
I don't understand.
I knifed him.
I don't understand the mechanism.
I fucking hate hunting.
Alright nice.
At least I got ammo.
It's fine.
I got ammo.
This was all I wanted.
I don't need a crouch.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Oh.
Door with an insignia.
I don't have that.
How do I get to there?
All those years of training.
The police academy didn't train me for this.
The house?
Do I try to go back into the house?
How do I get in the house?
Oh there's a door.
Sorry.
That one thing I didn't see.
Let me in!
I have a warrant!
But please don't check it!
Hello?
I don't like this.
I feel like...
I feel like there's definitely somebody up top.
God damn it.
Everything needs keys.
What?
Why do you need keys for?
I thought you guys were a safe town.
So safe.
Can I shoot these?
Can I shoot these guys?
Sure I brought...
Okay, look.
They should not be scared about people stealing stuff.
There's less things to worry about right now.
That should be the least of their worries.
People stealing.
I mean I'm not stealing.
I'm a government worker.
That doesn't count.
Let's see...
Oh, I don't know.
I feel like there might be somebody over here.
Aim but with knife equipped then use knife to stab.
Okay, you guys see it as if it's so easy.
They're not innocent.
Oh, fuck.
Oops, sorry.
Wait, what?
Why am I...
What?
Why am I instantly aiming?
What the fuck?
No, my two bullets!
What?
Why did I shot?
I just right clicked.
What happened?
I right clicked, guys.
I swear.
Wait, what?
What's going on?
I can't...
How do I...
My third bullet!
How do I get rid of it?
Okay.
Okay, I fixed it.
Okay, that was weird.
That was...
Oh, oh, oh!
Hello?
Can I...
I'm gonna stab him with my butter knife.
Oh, okay, never mind.
Whoa!
Shit!
Okay.
Don't worry.
Thick thighs save lives!
Nice.
How the fuck...
Oh, yeah, my...
You know what?
No, my thighs are like really...
My thighs...
My legs are just that strong.
I was gonna say, how the fuck was he not able to cut it with his...
fucking axe, but I can like stomp it?
I was like, what?
He had an axe!
That's just Leon's power.
Oh, now I have my flashlight.
The skill diff right there.
I was like so confused.
Wait, oh, is that Ashley?
Yeah, that's Ashley.
I can't shoot it.
I had to make sure.
You're not Ashley!
Oh, you're the other guy!
You're the guy people wish Leon was.
I'm sorry.
I didn't want to talk.
How observant, senor.
Now, say, you got a smoke?
And all those things will kill you.
Oh, well, maybe just untie me then, huh?
Oh, no, it's a chainsaw man.
Wait, who are you?
Stop right there.
Oh!
Oh, God!
Please!
Not the legs!
Only torso up!
Torso up, please!
Torso up!
Oh, shit.
Pro lives.
Chapter end!
Nice!
Okay, what's my results?
I got...
I performed a stealth kill.
Oh, I did all of that!
Appearance that everything changes.
Oh, I did everything.
Nice.
Okay.
Shift.
Save game.
Okay.
Nice.
It's okay.
I need someone better than Ashley.
Who the fuck are you?
Okay, this is fucked up for me to say he looked like...
Queen Elizabeth II's husband.
May he rest in peace.
I like how everyone was like, Adam Sandler.
Not expecting that.
It was like, Adam Sandler?
And then I'm like...
Him.
No, no.
That's good.
The jacket's gone.
Now he can see my games.
Wait, his name is actually Adam Sandler?
Whoa, that's awfully close, man.
We're bros, right?
Bro, it's just... Whoa!
Oh!
It's okay, bro.
Oh my god!
Bro, are we like best friends now?
Oh my god, bro.
Do you feel this?
Do you feel this chemistry right now, bro?
Oh shit!
That's how fast male friendships go.
Bro.
I know like male best... like...
Male friends is basically like...
You don't know any details about their personal lives...
But they're there for you, bro.
When guys are best friends...
And then they're like...
You know...
What's his family life now, right now?
And you're like...
I don't know, bro.
But we're gonna be playing some fucking Call of Duty later on on Friday.
True, bro.
It's like, what's his job?
Bro, I don't fucking know.
But his IGN is like...
Uh...
Major Hawk.
Bro, so true.
Yo, my stuff!
I hoarded so many items!
Don't know who their names are.
They're just my bro.
Wait, I should take this chain and like...
And then use the chain as a fucking whip.
I don't know.
Wait, where's my bro?
Bro, he already left me, bro?
Bro!
It's fucked up, bro.
At least I have my herbs.
Oh, no.
Bro, he already left me?
What the fuck?
I thought we're homies!
I didn't know the real name of one of my friends until two years later...
Because everyone called him by his nickname.
Bro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Alan.
Bro, left me.
Yo, not the stealth, bro.
Oh, nice.
My kitchen knife.
You can perform a wide swinging slash.
You can also do quick slash with space.
Okay.
I'll be like...
Ha ha!
Wait.
Ha.
Ha!
Okay, there you go.
Thanks, bro.
I hate this.
Why did they make this stuff?
Was this...
Was this in the original game?
I don't remember this.
Khan, thank you for the tent.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
This sucks.
I must have like deleted this portion from my mind.
Bro.
I definitely don't remember this.
Okay.
If you sneak behind...
Oh, I've already done that before.
Hello.
Shh.
I'm trying to find my bro.
Nice.
Another kitchen knife.
Have you seen him?
What's this?
That's my stuff!
Where's my stuff?
Where's my jacket.
Oh, my.
What the fuck?
I should be wearing shorts.
Oh, look, turn around.
Oh, he did not turn around, guys.
Guys, I don't think he turned around.
Nice.
I did it.
Nice, you did it.
Yay!
Oh, wait.
Okay.
You have a knife.
You're British now!
London Simulator, Jesus Christ.
You have a knife.
Wow!
Well, I never needed to know that, apparently.
You have a knife.
You can parry an attack with space.
When a prompt appears in the bottom right corner, you can successfully...
parry if you press it before the prompt appears.
Time it right and an enemy will be...
Wow, that was...
That would have been good to know earlier.
Um, well...
I beat him.
I killed him.
So, it's fine.
Okay, even if you press it before the prompt, time it right and then...
Okay.
You need to time this right.
How do I do this?
Okay.
Oh, I did it.
Oh my god, I'm learning.
Oh my fucking god.
Can't open this.
No!
My gear!
Leon!
Kick him with your fucking legs!
You used this...
Oh, wait.
Can I kill this rat?
Okay.
Walk on it.
Nice and more kitchen dives.
What I've always wanted.
How the fuck do I get my shit?
Give me my stuff!
Give it to me!
Let me in!
Okay, I can't get it.
Did I get caught?
Don't worry, I have this window.
I don't think I got caught, there's no way.
There's no way.
He's just talking to his friend.
There's no way, I have this window.
See, I told you, I didn't get caught!
Okay, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
There's no way he's gonna turn around.
Turn around, ba da da da da da da da da da.
Not yet, not yet, not yet, not yet!
Okay, nice.
Alright, thank you for the money.
Just gonna mug him real quick.
Alright.
Open.
Okay, nothing here.
Oh, I can open this.
Hello.
My gun!
I'll never use a knife ever again.
Oh god.
I gotta go fast.
Please Leon!
Your legs!
Leon!
Oh god.
Nice!
Okay, I got all my stuff.
I'll never have to use my knife ever again.
I'll be taking these back.
Nice.
Okay.
And then unlock here.
And I don't have a key.
Where the fuck are the keys?
Where are the keys?
Okay, let's craft this real quick.
Wait, actually...
I'm just gonna put this...
Wait, what?
What's this?
Is this my storage?
What is this?
Is that storage?
I don't know what this is.
This is trash?
Okay.
That's the ground?
Why the fuck does it look like a case?
How was I supposed to know that?
Crap.
I need shotgun shells.
Bye, god.
Alright, yeah, it's more space.
Let's put this here.
Tetris.
Whoa!
Friend!
Hello?
Mr. Merchant?
Stranger.
Who's that?
That's your new best friend!
Your new bro!
Let's do some business then.
What's this?
Get rid of the rats that take...
We don't know they're carrying any beret...
Oh, hey!
Wait, I can go back and get rid of the rats.
I should have got rid of the rats earlier.
Guys, I could have got rid of them earlier.
I know there's one of you right here.
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
Come on.
I'm gonna shank you.
Let me shank you.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Fuck, I think I need to shoot it.
He's too fast.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, look at him go!
Please.
Walk into my crosshair.
Bro!
Bro, he's so fast!
Okay, he's gonna tire himself out.
There we go.
I should have just done that.
I should have just laid for him to tire himself out.
There you are.
Okay, let me walk away from you.
Where are you?
Alright, tire yourself out.
Come on, tire yourself out.
There we go.
Where's the last rat?
Oh, there you are.
Alright.
Alright, come on!
You're gonna waste up all your energy!
That sugar's gonna die down!
There you go.
Nice.
Yes.
Yeah.
New York experience!
Alright, done.
I got the rats.
Yeah, I did.
What are you selling?
Trading?
But you didn't say the thing!
Merchant request.
Once you've completed a task received from blue request note, you can claim the reward by talking to the merchant.
Yeah!
You've proven yourself reliable.
I did it!
Yeah!
I swear to God, the bullets were more...
That's not...
He didn't say the thing.
Wait, but he didn't say the thing.
Oh, I need to fix my knife.
Yeah.
$4000?!
Bro!
Who gives a fuck about my knife?!
I'm gonna sell shit right now.
He has a no large can be sold.
Bro!
I'm just...
I'll just use my kitchen knife!
Why should I fucking...
Bro, why should I fix it when I have perfectly good kitchen knives?
It'll be worth it.
Okay, let me sell this first.
Okay, I'm gonna sell these two.
And...
I don't need this, right?
Yeah.
That is not usable anymore.
It's not the same.
Welcome to capitalism.
I'm gonna sell some of my fucking kitchen knives.
Alright.
Can I sell this key now?
I don't remember.
The racking will be the most discheesed with you.
Airway Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I won't need a parry if I have my gun!
Alright, so I think I got everything I need.
Boop!
Okay, two... FINE!
God, that was a lot of money.
I'm gonna sell this.
Okay.
Durability?
Right?
You want me to...
You want me to increase the durability?
Okay, this is time.
This is time for you to shine.
This is backseat time.
Durability?
Okay, durability.
What else?
What else do we need, guys?
What else should we...
There's durability?
Oh, I thought that was my fucking gun.
I was like, there's no fucking way there's durability on gun.
Case upgrade?
Okay.
Where is case upgrade?
Bye?
Okay, case upgrade.
I have enough money for that.
Alright, case upgrade.
Alright, what else?
What else do I need to upgrade, guys?
Wait, I can trade the spinels?
What do I trade it for?
Oh!
Get the Punisher?
How have we procured these curiosities?
Do I need that?
I don't need that.
I have you guys.
The rifle?
Do you get the scope free with the rifle?
Is the rifle that good?
This one?
I don't have space for it.
Is it that good?
Is it actually that good?
No, I meant the rifle.
Is this the rifle?
Yeah.
Yes?
Okay.
Fine.
I'll do it.
Okay, let me like...
I need to fix up my suitcase first.
Give me a sec.
I need to fix up my suitcase.
Let me... Let me fix this up.
Okay, storage.
Okay, we can...
Okay, let's put away...
How do I put away this?
Shift?
Uhhh...
Shit.
Okay.
Get in.
No!
Fuck!
Okay!
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize that I was dragging it!
No!
My green herbs!
Okay, I learned that dragging it turns it into...
Dragging it turns it into like... Yeah, I learned that today.
I wonder if this fits...
Does this fit?
I don't... How big is that fucking...
How big is it?
Customized case.
How do I take you to the storage?
Oh, auto sort?
No, what does the auto sort do?
Oh...
Just buy and use auto sort.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna buy now.
Okay.
I should have enough.
Just make sure...
Just make your space...
Okay.
This is awkward.
Okay, I can...
I figured this out.
Oh, I can... Oh, I know!
I know.
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
This is easy!
I'll just put this up here.
Wait, what?
I can't drag this?
Oh, okay.
God damn it.
I'm so stupid.
I can't read.
God, how do I function as a person sometimes?
Look at all my kitchen knives though.
There you go.
Yay!
Ba-da-dum.
Ba-dum-bum-bum-bum.
Do I have ammo for this gun?
Wait a minute.
Yes!
I did it!
Pull it straight through their heads!
Yeah, we do not have ammo.
Oh!
Thank you!
I got a scope!
Yes.
Thank you.
That's how you keep your customers!
Alright, I have no money now.
Now I'm actually broke.
Can I like, buy ammo?
Do you have ammo for me?
I don't know if he has ammo.
No, he does not.
Okay.
What's both?
Losing resources and...
No, I don't.
Guys, he doesn't have ammo, guys.
He does not have ammo.
I don't have... Do I have money for the...
Oh, wait.
This one?
Alright.
Okay.
Our map is updated now.
Oh!
I see!
Locked drawer, treasure, treasure.
Okay, I see.
Nice.
Oh!
Free ammo!
Dino, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Also defeats the purpose of a Tetris inventory system.
Think of the principles!
Good thing I couldn't figure it out!
Because I didn't realize it was hold, alt.
Hahaha!
That's your streamer!
I didn't figure out you were supposed to hold alt key!
Hahaha!
So I had to do it the real way!
You know you can trade this to another to receive as a reward for valuable goods?
Oh, that's cool!
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
What's this?
Hexagon shaped slot, treasure...
Which way do I go?
Okay.
Oh my god, it's all...
The objective is all over there!
The eagle...
When will I ever need to use...
I guess I'll use my rifle for bosses.
And the little guys...
The little guys will be used for...
That's my streamer!
Hahaha!
I'll use the pistol for the little guys.
There's no way I'm using...
Wait a minute.
There's no way I'm using the rifle...
I'm using the pistol.
Oh, we have to attach the scope?
Where the fuck... Oh, I do!
Bam.
There we go.
Attached.
Get closer!
That's right!
There we go.
Get closer!
I don't want you to waste my legs!
Oh shit, I accidentally...
Get closer!
There we go.
Nice!
Come on!
You're almost there!
Nice, I don't have to waste my knife on you.
That's good.
Thank you, Granny!
Are there any bear traps?
No bear traps.
Oooh!
I don't like this.
This doesn't seem very stable!
Oh, what's that?
What's that?
Okay, I'm gonna go down.
Hey guys!
I don't know if this is stable or not.
Oh, look at all these grannies!
Look at all these grannies over there!
Okay, I'm just gonna...
It's okay, they don't know where I am.
Right?
Okay, that's fucked up that I missed.
No, he doesn't know!
See?
He's so confused!
Oh!
Goodbye!
Look at them!
Goodbye, Granny!
Thank you, Granny!
Don't worry!
There's like inflatable balloons down there!
It's like up!
Can you walk down the stairs for me?
Oh my god, not that slow though.
It's okay.
There you go.
Easy.
Wait, are they not gonna walk up to me?
Why would I use rifles?
Rifles are so expensive ammo!
If I can shoot them with a handgun like this, If I can shoot them with a handgun like this, I don't need the rifle.
Okay, not like that though.
Oh, now I missed!
I hit every single shot earlier.
But now that I get a little cocky, I start missing.
I see...
Oh, fuck you!
Okay, where is...
I need a fucking...
Let me equip...
Register this as a shortcut real fast.
Alright, I've had enough.
I've had enough.
Alright, dude, fuck this guy though.
There you go.
Alright.
Okay, I don't need to use the rifle on her though.
Watch.
Alright, here you go.
There, see?
I can do this.
I'm not wasting my fucking ammo.
Guys, I can...
Look, see?
For some reason, that guy didn't work.
But first...
Oh my god, that was like the only person I missed shots on.
Everybody else I've hit.
Guys, pistol ammo isn't wasting ammo!
They're so fucking...
It's so easy to find pistol ammo!
Why is the wind so big now?
Is it because I killed everybody?
Are they mad?
Why is the wind mad at me?
What did I do?
Alright.
Why is there boss music?
Guys, what did I do?
I don't want to drop down.
The wind god is angry at you.
There's nobody up top though.
Oh, okay.
The wind stopped.
I don't want to go down.
I'm scared.
What the fuck were you?
Bro, he just ran at me.
Okay, there.
Oh!
Shit.
There you go.
Nice.
I don't like this.
Oh, what the fuck!
Oh shit, I didn't realize there were more!
Oh!
There are so many!
What?
Okay.
No wonder the wind gods were mad.
That's a good casualty.
Oh god.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Did you see that though?
Okay.
Oh shit!
No!
Now they're grabbing me!
Please let me go!
Okay.
Here we go.
There we go.
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
Woo!
That's fine.
We're fine.
It's fine.
There we go.
See?
Not a waste!
I got my ammo back.
I got my ammo back, guys.
It's not a waste.
Please, let me in.
Woo!
Please don't tell me this is never ending.
Guys, I swear to god, is this...
I swear, does this end?
Does this end?
I hear a lot.
This is never ending?
This is
never ending?
What do you mean?
Let me in.
Oh, hey, but...
I didn't realize this is never ending!
I wasted so much!
Please.
Oh, god.
Where am I?
Ah!
Good.
God damn it!
Okay, I'm okay!
Ah!
You were too fast!
My knife!
It's okay.
Everything is fine!
Fuck off.
Oh, god.
Thighs.
Your... toes.
Fucking fuck me up now!
It's fine.
We're fine.
Where's the ladder?
Wait!
There's no ladder here?
Guys, I didn't realize there was no ladder.
I thought there was.
Guys, you think this is a choice?
With me running in circles?
I'm literally panicking!
Alright, that's fine.
We're okay.
Oh, god.
There's so many!
Oh!
Sheik!
Oh, no!
Oh, god!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh, god.
Oh!
Nice!
Did you guys see that parry, though?
It's okay.
Woooo!
Where am I?
Drop down, Leon!
Drop down!
Please!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, up top we go, up top we go, up top we go!
And then... we just shoot them off the ladder.
Who has it?
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
Is there anybody on the ladder?
Here we go.
Guard the ladder!
The ladder's shot!
It's fine.
They can't get me up on the ladder!
It's the ladder shot!
They can't get up!
There's one ladder!
I only have four bullets.
Oh no, they're getting up!
They're getting up, guys!
I fucked up!
Okay.
It's fine.
I... It's not fine, guys.
This is... Is it fine?
Are we good now?
Are we...
Are we okay?
Are... Are we...
Guys!
It's okay!
We don't need the pistol!
It's fine!
It's fine.
We...
This is exactly why we don't play hardcore.
This is exactly why.
There we go.
This is one of the big reasons.
This is exactly why Doki cannot do hardcore.
Okay, here we go.
We're going to grab...
The amount of resources that I took.
Boom.
Alright.
We're good.
Everything is fine now.
We...
We survived.
It...
So it wasn't never ending.
So that was a lie!
That was a fucking lie!
Whoever said this was never ending!
There was an end!
There was...
Thank fucking god there was an end!
Alright.
Hello.
Is there any loot here?
Hello?
I went through so much.
God, I went through so much.
Guys, please, where are the loot?
Boof.
Okay.
Just gonna make sure I...
Make sure all these doors can be opened.
Whoop.
Hello?
Oh hey!
There's a little chest here!
Oh there's a key!
What does this key do?
Okay, I can go up though.
Open the locker?
Alright, get jumpscared in 3, 2, 1.
Oh.
Okay.
That's cool.
Alright, thank god.
Missing...
Hexagon.
Oh, I got the hexagon emblem.
The item that I was supposed to get.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the key supposed to go?
More lockers?
Did I miss out more?
Is there more lockers down there?
Oh.
Oh there is.
Jumpscare in 3, 2, 1.
See?
Look at that guys!
It's like I didn't waste all my handgun ammo.
See?
Alright, let's see.
Oh there's more.
See?
There's more!
I didn't get punished!
Look at that!
Not punished.
Got more handgun ammo.
Look at that!
Wait, what?
I heard somebody over there?
What?
Hey, did you guys see that?
Where?
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Where did you come from lady?
All your fucking family's dead!
Where did you come from?
No!
The fire!
My ambience!
Bro, she's late to the party!
Her husband died like 10 minutes ago!
Bro!
She's so fashionably late!
What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
Oh shit!
Jeez!
Thanks for lighting that though.
Nice, we got the ruby.
Did I use the key?
Wait, did I just use the key?
For that?
I did, right?
That was the key, right guys?
No?
She was also sleeping in.
The key is for the small drawers?
Where is the key though?
Where do I use it?
I already opened everything here.
Uh, yeah.
Got everything.
I need to loot her body though.
Let me climb up that ladder.
A small locked drawer?
Where the fuck is that?
There were so many.
Oh my gosh, thank god.
I got the ammo I wanted.
I wasted on those two ladies.
I passed by money?
No.
No, we can't let that happen.
Back at the- Oh no, I have to fucking go all the way back there?
Alright, I did it.
I killed everybody in the village.
It's alright guys.
I did a good thing today.
Hello.
Take a look.
Save game.
Alright.
I think I can afford to- Oh, I cannot.
I'm so broke.
Nevermind.
Wait, I can!
Okay.
Guys.
I feel like I can upgrade my gun.
Guys, not gonna lie.
But like, I don't know.
What do you think?
The investment on the power of my weapon.
My pistol.
Yeah?
Is it worth it?
No, I actually need actual advice.
Is it actually worth it?
Yeah?
Okay.
It's worth it?
Okay, power.
Alright.
I mean, I've been fucking using that.
I've been fucking shooting people in the head.
There is a better one?
What do you mean?
There's a better free gun?
Not worth it long run?
Okay.
Yeah, I think it's worth it.
Do I just not do it?
Wait until we get a better free gun?
I can sell it better?
Not seeing anything you like, stranger.
Okay, but when do I get the better pistol?
What chapter?
Okay.
Guys, I need to know.
What chapter do I get the better free gun?
Worth it now?
Okay.
People are saying it's worth it now.
In like two...
Okay, I'm fucking investing in this.
I'm investing this.
You guys said in one to three.
In like chapter three or four.
And I'm like, yeah.
No, we're fucking investing this.
You guys don't even know.
That's way later.
Exactly.
Okay, we're gonna fucking open up the chest.
Wherever that is.
What is this?
Here?
The lock...
Oh, there it is.
The locked drawer.
Yeah, there it is.
Nice.
Boom.
What's this?
It's a mask.
Can I sell this?
This is also...
There must be another treasure over there too.
Okay.
It's okay.
I can make my money back.
There's a treasure right here.
Right?
Like here?
Oh, I did open this.
Nice.
There's a sapphire.
We might be able to find another of those like pots thing that we can use to double the value.
Nice.
Yeah, we need to find the pot though.
So we can double the value of this.
All right.
So...
Oh, I can add it on the mask.
Nice.
All right.
Key items.
I'll just do it now.
Anything...
Gems.
Okay.
Red, blue, yellow.
If I find red, blue, yellow, I can get one point.
Okay.
I'm going to see what gems I can get before I add it.
Yeah.
I'm going to see what gems I can get.
All right.
Save.
Daniel!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
All right.
Put that eagle in.
Oh, I have to rotate it?
I don't know.
Oh.
Oh!
I see!
Okay.
There you go.
I didn't realize I could turn it around.
Okay.
I see.
I can see it now.
I definitely see.
There you go.
Open sesame.
Okay.
I can see it now.
Where's Ashley?
Oh.
Wait.
I can stealth now.
My kitchen knife.
This is it.
This is what my kitchen knife is for.
Stop walking.
There.
Oh!
What the fuck was that?
Shit!
Okay.
That's awkward.
Where did this man come from?
Oh!
Oopsie!
No, ma'am.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That was a little awkward though.
That was...
Whoops!
Hey, don't turn.
Don't turn.
Nice.
Oh!
No!
Fuck!
I just saw it.
God damn it!
Okay.
It's fine.
It's just...
Oh!
Just a little flesh wound.
Just a little...
God damn it!
Thank you for the 50 gifted chests!
Thank you!
I appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
It was worth it.
Can't believe crouch was E.
It's okay.
Man, I think with all these areas, I was definitely supposed to stealth.
Whoops.
Does this work?
Oh, nice.
Sapphire.
Wait.
Do I have two sapphires?
Okay.
What was the combo?
Oh, if I had two gemstones of the same color.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
If I had three...
Wait.
Three of the same color though.
Let me find another blue gem.
Let me find another blue sapphire.
Oh!
Resource.
Who the fuck crouches with some sick fuck that thinks actually it's important?
Oh, okay.
I'm not sure.
Let me make sure.
Oh, I missed out on the bullets.
Oh, my bullets.
Ammo!
Where's the ammo?
Where is it?
Ammo?
Oh, there it is.
Nice!
Okay.
I need a...
Let me like craft some ammo real quick.
Oh!
Okay.
We need rifle ammo.
That's pretty cool.
For sure.
And then do we have enough for shotgun?
No.
Okay.
Let's just put this here.
And then...
Just Tetris this just a little bit.
It's fine.
Let me just eat an egg.
A small amount.
You know what?
One egg wouldn't hurt.
Alright.
We're good.
We're gonna find more eggs anyway.
What if I shoot a crow?
Can I get like a bonus?
Oh my god!
Crows get loot!
A hundred dollar... a hundred and fifty dollars.
That's like an AKKA right there.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
That's right.
I know you have money inside you now.
Now I know no bird is safe anymore.
No crow is safe.
The money crow.
The legends were true!
The money crow!
Wait, where's your money?
What the fuck?
How come you don't have money?
I got scammed.
One bullet is very expensive.
The fuck was my money crow?
Oh god.
Oh okay.
Nice.
Okay, not a waste.
Herb.
The influence is not what it once was.
Destroy the wine up doll.
Do not forgive those aristocrats.
Oh no.
Bourgeoisie versus the potterette.
Wait.
Is that what they're called?
It's been a while since university.
Okay.
Boop!
Alright.
Spin over.
Oh gunpowder.
We need that.
Wait, I can make the shotgun!
Right?
Is it 12?
Oh no, it's 12.
I cannot make it.
They got everything?
No, there's so much loot here.
What else is there?
Treasure?
Where's the treasure?
Do I shoot this?
Woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah!
No, they don't.
What do you mean?
There's nobody behind me.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Woah!
Wait, is that Chasel?
Is that Chasel?
Is that...
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay.
It's okay.
This is what it's for.
This way.
Can I kill him?
Can he be...
Okay.
Guys, before I waste more ammo.
Can he be killed?
Okay, that's good enough.
Chainsaw Man, please!
I need a reload!
Chainsaw Man!
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Yes, we did it!
Oh, we did it.
Alright, that's good.
That's good.
Thank god for them stopping to let me check my chat.
Okay, we should be able to make this now, right?
Yeah!
Alright, nice.
And then here.
What?
Oh, it's circular.
I'm so fucking stupid.
Yellow.
Not the...
Guys.
The square shape goes in the...
Okay, sorry.
I don't know my shapes as well, guys.
I'm just a little special.
I don't know my shapes.
Where is that?
There's like loot somewhere here.
See that?
I'm standing where loot is.
I'm looking up.
To this?
Oh!
God, I'm so smart.
I looked up, guys.
Guys, I looked up.
Okay, we got it.
Oh, close the hatch?
What?
You can do that?
Oh.
How was I supposed to know you can close this?
It's okay.
It's still money.
Now you got your circle.
No!
It's ruined!
It's okay.
Just...
Just a little mistake.
It's fine.
Alright, let me...
Is this Ashley?
Ashley?
It definitely made this longer.
I swear it did not take this long to fucking find Ashley.
They definitely made this game much longer than the first original.
Wait.
This trap is being used.
Reload the save.
I'm not gonna reload the save.
Chat.
Girl, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Take the loot.
Just don't shoot me.
It's too late.
Now that I know you have money inside.
What if you fucking...
What if you're like...
Holding out on me, huh, crew?
What if you try to hold out on me?
Facts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't like this.
Can I go from outside?
Oh, I need a key.
Maybe I can like...
Set these back.
No?
Why are some traps like on and some aren't?
It's weird.
Okay, I've learned.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
You can't catch me this time.
That's fucking right.
I figured it out.
You can't catch me now.
Oh my god, that scared me for some reason.
Hello?
Any bear traps?
Boop.
Any bears?
Okay, there's two...
There's two treasures inside.
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Hello?
I'm sorry.
It's the
toilet...
Oh, no.
Chainsaw man 2.0.
Lord Kurosu, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Toilet bed.
We meet again.
It's like things never change.
Wait, you meant crows were holding out on you?
Oh, well, take my money anyway.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I'm not too shabby.
Someone has shown up their neighbors.
Just like... just like before.
Oh, what's wrong with...
Why did you scratch their faces?
It's messed up.
I'll rotate the other way though.
Oh, I can't look at the back?
Okay.
I guess I didn't want to.
This is...
Key!
Nice.
Got my key.
What's this treasure?
Oh?
Okay.
Oh, Q and E?
No, I can just spin it.
No, I meant turn it.
I want to turn the photo to the back.
Okay.
It's nice to know Toilet Man is still there.
Oh.
Um...
What is this puzzle?
What the fuck is this puzzle?
Is it from this one photo?
Is this...
Oh, there it is!
It's left click!
God, this is the worst though.
At last, flesh of our flesh, blood of our blood.
Give thanks and rejoice.
Okay.
That was useless anyway.
Alright.
Where do we do this puzzle?
Oh!
Wait.
Let me reread that.
Sorry.
My memory is not that great.
I'm only good at remembering parking spaces.
Like where we park and stuff.
What is it?
Flesh of our flesh, blood of our blood.
Oh, I see.
Give thanks and rejoice.
Wait.
What?
Flesh of our flesh, blood of our...
Oh, sorry.
Can I just like kick the thing like always?
That doesn't make sense.
Flesh of our flesh, blood of our blood?
This is not a clue.
That's not the clue.
I need to keep looking.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, it's a hand grenade.
I can barely see it.
Where did we find the clue?
Oh.
I found it.
Let's see if I can find a clue.
Oh, doesn't matter.
Gunpowder.
Alright.
Craft shotgun ammo.
I need that for sure.
Oh, that doesn't matter.
Howie...
Who does...
Puzzle...
The other photos?
That photo doesn't make sense.
Wait.
Isn't that the...
Oh, I thought that was the...
Oh, it's upstairs.
Okay.
Make sure there's nothing here.
Nice, chicken egg.
Is that in the oven?
Why is there a chicken egg in the oven?
Ma'am!
I'm not gonna judge you, but ma'am!
Alright, hello?
I think my bro is up here.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, herbs!
I can combine this.
Nice.
Okay, safe.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, that's it!
Wait, what was it?
Sorry.
Crop pig baby.
Okay, we got this.
Crop pig...
Wait, why am I saying that loud?
You guys can tell me.
Crop... pig...
baby.
Nice.
Ooh, what's this?
Crystal marble.
That's it?
I should be able to steal all these other things inside the drawer and sell it to the...
Sell it to the...
Fucking...
Let's see...
Wow!
Zap!
Oh, shit!
My kitchen knife!
Okay, I thought... I didn't realize he was the mutated guy.
I didn't realize.
It's okay, I have so many kitchen knives.
Hey...
No, that's not the poop man.
That can't be!
There's no way!
Hey!
Did the poop man mutate?
Is that actually you?
Oh my god!
It's the poop man!
Is that gold?
It is him!
I knew I should have double shanked.
God damn it.
My one mistake.
I didn't double tap.
Okay, save.
I'm just gonna be paranoid saving this entire time.
Alright, hello!
Oh, it was... I can't sell this.
Wait, what?
Oh.
I hate this though.
I hate this so much.
There we go.
Should be it.
Wait, what?
This should be it.
No, it's not.
Okay.
I hate this.
Wait, this should be it.
Right?
Oh, I'm gonna die.
No.
I hate this.
What?
This is so sad.
Okay.
Okay, this should be it.
Oh, this should be it!
There we go.
Nice.
I'm smarter than a child.
October 10th.
The weather has been strange of late.
The wheat withers and the cows grow thin.
December 8th.
There are signs of famine.
It is true.
We lack the means to work the fields.
But Lord Saddler's orders are absolute.
January 30th.
Thirty people have starved to death.
Five cows will be slaughtered.
March 11th.
The patriarchs gather to cast lots.
Six more chosen for Lord Saddler.
April 8th.
More today.
Four more today.
Eleven more today.
Two outsiders got lost and wandered into the village.
We took them to the altar for the ritual.
No need to cast lots today.
Oh.
Alright.
So it's like the lottery system.
Yay!
Oh, there he is.
Aww.
Oh, I thought he would like fucking show up.
Okay.
Oh, the insignia key!
What's that for?
No!
I forgot to take the bullets!
Bring me back!
No!
My handgun!
Oh!
Bro?
Oh wait!
Ada?
That's not my bro.
Not my bro.
I can't believe it.
Where's my bro?
Where's my best friend?
Alright.
Chapter results.
Oh, we got a lot.
Yay!
Money!
Nice.
81% accuracy.
You guys are good.
I think that's pretty good.
I'm pretty sure you guys are like, not 100%.
Not my streamer.
Not my gamer.
I've got that intel you requested on Louis Serra.
It seems he used to be a researcher for Umbrella.
Umbrella?
I should have left him in that bag to rot.
I'm sending you the details.
Take a look.
I saw a mod where you can like change Leon into Wesker.
You can play...
You can just play as Wesker.
Please.
When will I see Ashley?
That's all I want.
What's this?
Ashley?
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, I guess I can look at him again.
Alright.
Wait.
Did I grab all these?
I did, right?
Oh yeah, I did.
Okay.
I'm gonna go up then.
Alright.
Oh, I don't have Ashley.
Okay, never mind.
That doesn't matter.
Okay.
Okay, apparently I can't jump.
Leon?
Apparently, you can't fucking jump and grab onto this ladder.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
I don't care that much, I guess.
I'm scared now.
I feel like I'm just gonna meet someone.
Leon can't jump.
At the end of chapter four?
When did Ashley take this long to get?
I swear.
I'm pretty sure that they made this game longer.
They definitely made this game longer.
I wanted to see my fucking Hot Topic Ashley.
Okay.
Hello?
I don't know.
I don't trust this.
I don't trust this!
Hello?
Oh my god.
I don't trust this at all.
I hear a dog.
Dog?
No, dog!
Don't worry, dog!
I help you!
Don't worry!
It's okay.
I'll spray it.
Wait!
You're supposed to give me XP!
Or gold!
Alright.
Well, goodbye, dog.
Okay, Insignia is like behind me.
Alright.
The fuck was my gold?
The crows gave me gold.
Alright, here I go.
Use.
We saved dad.
Alright.
Where's my bro?
I take my bro or Ashley.
Oh, I don't like this.
Ooh.
Turn on your flashlight.
I don't like how he doesn't turn on his flashlight instantly when it's dark.
I don't like that.
It's dark!
Okay, is this safe?
No?
Just a random shed here?
Oh.
What did I do with this random shed?
Alright.
Too dark.
I don't like this.
This is way too dark.
Turn on your flashlight.
Leon, please!
Leon!
I'm gonna fucking turn... fucking bring out my shotgun at this rate.
Like...
I don't like this.
Oh.
Wait.
There he is.
Wait, there's a villager.
Hello?
Oh, that's another village.
This is another village I'm gonna slaughter?
Because I don't know what stealth is?
I guess it is.
Hello, villagers!
I come here to kill all of you!
What kind of stealth?
Hello?
Where are the villagers?
Another village.
Another slaughter.
Hello?
Oh wait, this is the first village.
Oh wait, I've been here.
This is the first village.
Alright.
Let's see... I should be able to get this drawer now.
Yeah.
And there's a treasure here too.
Wait, I can't be able to... where's the objectives?
How the fuck do I get over here?
What?
How the fuck do I... Jesus Christ, what is this map?
Alright, let's grab... I don't like this.
Hello?
Hello guys?
Alright, let's open this door for... aww, come on.
Who set this trap back?
Huh?
Hello?
I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
I'm so nervous.
Yeah, why is this village so fucking quiet?
Mmm.
Mmmmm.
Hello?
Quiet village doesn't make me happy.
Where do I go?
Do I go all the way back?
Because they're playing bingo.
True, they're still playing bingo right now.
AHHHHH!
What's going on?
What the fuck?
There's bad wolves!
There's bad...
Nooooo!
Oh god, oh god.
There's bad wolves!
That's fucking right.
Nooo, shit!
Shit, shit, okay, okay.
I'm gonna heal.
Please reload.
Please!
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh my god, my fucking shotgun.
Holy shit.
I can't believe there were bad wolves.
If evil, why bad of a wolf?
What happened to the karma system?
I save wolf!
I get reward!
The karma system was a lie.
This is why you never do good things.
Wait, what?
Is that more wolves?
This is exactly why you don't do any good thing ever again.
It was never worth it.
Why save wolves when wolves still evil?
How the fuck do I use this map?
Guys, I'm fucking stupid.
I guess the ladder?
Ah, fucking hell!
Alright.
Oh hey, I should take this herb though.
Might as well.
I guess ladder?
Where is this?
Oh!
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, I don't like this at all.
Hello?
I'm just gonna...
shoot some boxes.
Hello?
Hello, is that rat?
That's a rat.
Okay.
Okay, that was just a rat.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna...
Just gonna...
fucking destroy your barrels.
Alright, nothing to be scared of.
Oh, what is this?
What is this?
Oh...
Oh!
Honestly, I thought they would just come out of the trash.
Lowkey thought they were gonna...
Oh, hey there.
Oh, fuck.
Thighs!
Save me now!
Oh!
There you go!
Sick thighs!
Let's go.
Wait, wait, is that a chainsaw?
No, that was not a chainsaw.
Okay.
I'm happy for my thighs.
Nice.
Hey, we're good.
Oh, we're good.
We're okay.
Thighs saves lives.
Yeah, that's right.
This life, too.
Two.
I'm gonna make sure... did I get everything here?
Let's see...
How to go to the door with the insignia...
Yeah, there's nothing here.
I think there's nothing here for me to loot.
So I can go to the church now.
Boop!
Hello!
Hello?
What's that?
AHH!
What the fuck was that?!
Bad snake!
Oh, I got a snake.
Nice.
Can I sell this?
Oh my god, my favorite fucking kitchen knife.
That's definitely what I need.
Ooh...
Is this their church?
Where the fuck...
What kind of church is this?
Okay, I don't need to look at this man's face for the fifth time.
That's a giant skull!
That's...
Yeah, where the...
What the fuck?
How did they get that?
Sleep well and flourish, dear child.
As your body grows, your mother shall sew new small clothes.
As seven quintal of wheat and half a bowl a day, you have outgrown your pen.
Flourish, dear child, for the sake of your brothers and sister who cannot...
That's a John-ass fucking skull.
Whose head is that?
Whose fucking head is that?
Oh my god, that boy grew!
That's a big boy.
I think I'm running out of inventory space.
That is a lot of heads.
Okay, the smell in this place must not be great.
Not gonna lie.
This is not the best smelling place.
Merchant?!
Nice.
That's good.
That means I'm safe.
What's this?
Sick of constantly running out of everything.
I'm gonna go buy some ammo.
Well, I got a treat for you.
The bolt through is something else, mate.
It's a bolt that can be retrieved and reused.
So you can keep shooting forever.
Also, don't forget to buy the bolt recipe to turn your extra knives into, well, bolts.
Nothing to worry about ammo again.
And that's not all.
You can fix the bolts with attachable mines.
Skip ad.
Merchant, if you are telling me to buy your bolts...
That means...
That means it's a scam.
You have too much in stock.
You can't fool me.
I used to...
I've told this story before.
But for those who are new here...
Back when I was in, like, middle school...
And I used to live in Asia...
I used to sell, like, overpriced, like, anime shit to, like, people in America on eBay.
I used to run an eBay store.
You can't fool me, merchant.
You can't...
I was a fast lay.
So in middle school, I opened up an eBay.
And I just sold, like...
Oh my god.
One of them was, like, Italia trading cards.
And, like...
Because, like, when I bought the trading cards, like, they were, like, you know, they were, like, super cheap when I was in Asia.
But then, like, people in America, they were trying to get, like, collectible cards from Italia.
Like, the most...
The collectible ones.
So then I sold individual cards on eBay.
The rare cards I had.
So it was you!
I...
I did that.
And I also sold, like, anime posters from, like, magazines.
Because, like, you can get, like, the...
You know, like, those anime magazines where you can get, like, posters and stuff?
It's...
Okay.
It wasn't a scam when people...
People back then could not do it.
They couldn't get it.
Like...
It's not a scam!
I was your only way to get these items!
And then...
So, like, you know, in, like, magazines, those anime magazines that has, like, posters of, like, anime characters and it's, like, exclusively only in these magazines?
So I bought those magazines and then I would sell the posters within the magazines.
Because, like, people really wanted them.
So you can't fool me, merchant!
You can't fool me!
That's something I would do.
I'd be like, hey guys.
You should buy this.
The world!
Very exclusive!
You can't fool me!
Look, I was in middle school.
Okay.
I gotta hustle.
Look, it was...
It was tough, guys.
Being in middle school.
We're trying to make money.
Yay!
It's supply and demand, bro!
Exactly!
Supply and demand!
Is there anything I can sell?
For sell... oh wait.
Is there any of them that are like...
that need gems?
No, okay.
We're gonna sell.
Sell...
We need to sell the...
Velvet blue, the vintage, the pearl.
Uh...
Do we sell...
Viper's left to sell for the Viper...
Oh!
Do I sell this now or later?
Yeah, but if I find a yellow sap...
If I find a yellow one...
then... wait, I have three?
But wouldn't... wait, actually, I'm gonna sell these three first.
Do I sell the Viper now?
I should?
Or when I find...
I could just wait until I find like...
Uh...
Sell now?
Okay.
Alright, I'll sell now.
Alright.
I'll sell it now.
I'll just sell these for now.
And then I'll do the others.
Apparently I have...
Okay, remove gemstones.
Okay, and they...
Wait, is the three the same color better?
Oh, it is!
Boop!
Okay, there we go.
I can just sell this.
Uh, so...
Buy my fucking mask.
Nice.
Ooh, that is a lot.
Alright, guys.
Should I buy anything or should I...
Guys, should I buy anything?
Or... uh...
Or do I upgrade?
Guys, what do I do?
Stop chat telling me wrong things!
Upgrade?
Okay, I'll upgrade.
What do I upgrade?
Uh, what should I upgrade?
Uh...
Tune up the knife?
Guys, I'm mostly using my kitchen knife though.
The nitro ability, sis?
Go get the...
Why would I need the TMP?
I don't think I need the TMP.
Guys...
I don't need it!
I have the pistol!
Guys, I don't need it.
I have the pistol.
Okay, I'll do the two.
I'll do the durability of my knife.
I'll do that.
And then...
Rifle upgrade?
Should I upgrade my rifle?
I can!
What do I upgrade?
Um...
Do I get power?
Or...
Power?
Okay, I'll do power.
Okay, I have enough money.
I can also power...
No, actually, I can... what do I do?
I have 20k.
Do I put all in on power?
All in?
Better snipers ahead?
Okay.
Power and reload speed.
Power and...
Capacity.
Okay, capacity or reload speed?
Reload?
Okay, I don't know, guys.
I have enough for either...
All in.
Oh, better sniper in...
Castle.
That's a long way.
Okay.
Absolutely.
I'll max power this then.
Alright.
I'll max power this.
Just for bosses.
Ultimate power.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
A girlfriend?
Oh, this is the snakes!
Delicious vipers.
Is there a snake charmer willing to...
Okay, this is the snake thing.
Alright.
Let's go.
Yeah, they 100% made this fucking long.
I would have met my bro by now.
I would have saw my bro!
Oh, there he is.
Nice.
Oh, I can sell this again.
Hello, stranger.
Hello.
I need you to buy my...
Hello, stranger.
Hello.
I need you to buy my...
Nice.
I'm gonna...
save again just so... just in case.
I had to get the treasure!
What do you mean wrong way?
There was treasure over there.
The lighting is so weird sometimes.
I'm learning.
This game is teaching me to look up.
Hello?
Who's there?
Whoa.
I made it!
Bro, are you here?
Bro?
Oh.
Hmm.
Okay.
Wait.
I might be able to stealth this.
He won't turn around, right?
Yeah?
Yeah.
There's you go.
Nice.
We let him dig his own grave.
Thank you for the money.
Honestly, I'm just killing them for the money at this point.
Like, that's more important.
It's all about the money.
Oh shit!
Whoa!
Bro!
Okay.
It dies.
Nice.
Wait, did I alert people?
Hey guys, did you guys hear that?
No, right?
Oh no.
Okay, that's good.
Nobody heard that.
Thank god.
What the fuck?
That's a random coffin over there.
Resources.
Nice.
That's okay.
His life didn't matter.
Thank fucking god.
It's alright.
Nobody knew.
We're fine.
People didn't like this guy anyway.
Nobody liked him!
Alright, will he have money?
Let's find out.
I knew it!
I knew you were holding out on me, you crows!
I'm fucking out!
I'm the loan shark.
I'm here to collect my pay.
I fucking knew those crows were holding out.
I knew it!
They can't get away from me!
I knew they were holding out.
My money!
It's our money now.
The church is sealed up.
And baby eagle?
Negative.
Nothing yet.
But they sure do have this place locked up tight.
I see.
I can think of one reason they'd want to do so.
Who would unlock it?
I'm perfectly safe!
I'll find a way in.
I'm a police officer!
Okay, we need like an emblem.
Climb over the...
I don't think we're climbing over anything on that.
I don't think so, guys.
There's some treasures here.
There's more treasures.
Can I go through here?
No, it's locked.
Alright, we're gonna go through here.
Wham!
Okay.
Hello?
What's this?
A pressed fro.
He out-sit has come.
What the fuck?
The key... I'll be held in the cave on the side.
The monster will...
Okay, the key... okay, I...
Cross the lake.
Okay, there we go.
That took me a while to comprehend.
Is this... is that Ashley?
Ashley!
What are you doing?
Keep her locked in the church until the appointed time.
This is not the outfit we picked for you!
Oh, no, not this.
Words.
That was a little difficult to understand.
I'm gonna read, okay?
Can I open this?
Oh, I can!
Okay, where do we go?
I'm gonna go outside first?
Cause there's something over here.
Ooh, I like this.
This is spooky!
I don't like that spooky scary it's giving me!
Okay, what's this?
The traitorous twins should not be allowed to rest in peace for joining that evil cult.
Wait, someone destroyed the emblems engraved upon their tombstones.
Oh, okay.
I just need to, like, destroy their graves.
Yeah.
That's something I can do.
Elegant headdress.
The fuck is that?
Oh my god, there is no space.
Oh, I need to craft, uh, shotgun shells.
Wait, is that small?
Okay, I can... yeah.
Always make shotgun shells.
Uh...
Wait...
Craft... fuck!
I should...
I forgot I had these guys too.
Can I combine them?
I cannot... okay.
Okay, this is...
I have a lot of grenades.
I have...
Woo!
Grave desecration!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Let's hope there's nobody back there.
There!
Alright.
Woo!
Oh, I can stash?
Oh, nevermind.
I thought I can, like...
Where are the twins?
What if I just...
Destroy every grave?
Does it matter?
It shouldn't matter.
What the...
It shouldn't...
It shouldn't matter, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it doesn't matter if I just destroy everybody's graves.
Like, who cares?
They're dead already.
Go for it.
Who's gonna fucking stop me?
Their parents?
Who's already dead?
Cause I'm pretty sure I've already killed everybody here.
Or eventually will.
There we go, we got one.
There we did it.
Yay.
You know what?
Just for good luck.
Boom.
There we go, we did it.
Yay!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Grave robber Doki.
We did it.
Yeah, who's gonna stop me?
Nobody!
I already killed everybody in this village.
I'm too powerful.
I don't know if I should be going up or down.
Oh, up for sure for the extra loot, I guess.
Flash grenades.
Do I have space still?
I do.
This is like...
This is gonna be an issue.
For sure.
This is definitely gonna be an issue later on down the line.
Hey, I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna get you.
Hey guys, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
No!
I don't need an auto-sort.
That's for pussies.
I'm a gamer.
Oh, hey.
Wait, no, I don't have the key for that.
Now I can go downstairs.
How do I put this in my storage?
Or is that...
How do I move this to my storage?
This is like...
Is this a storage?
Or like...
Can I put stuff in here?
Or do I have to use it?
Oh, only weapons!
Oh!
Oh, oh wait.
I can put sprays, right?
Can I put sprays?
Someone?
Someone let me put my sprays.
Where do I put that?
Shift.
Go in.
Oh, certain items only?
Oh, click it.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I don't need my sprays.
Okay, that's good.
I have way too many.
Thank you.
This is why I need back-seaters.
Okay, there you go.
I have way too fucking many sprays.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're already dead!
There's no brain going in there!
There's already brain dead!
There!
And also, they're in graves now.
They're either consumed by the parasite or they're in the graves.
So it doesn't matter.
Can I open this door side?
Whoo!
Yeah, they're already dead or they're dead-dead.
Exactly.
Wait, what?
I opened it that way, okay.
Yeah, there's already fucking food for worms!
There's like- oh, that's like the unlock.
Oh my god, it's all the way there.
The church key is there?!
The sub of- what the fuck?
Okay.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ!
Guys, okay, give me a sec.
How- I- I didn't look up how long this game is.
I'm actually curious.
Okay.
How long is Resident Evil 4 Remake?
Okay, 15- okay, original.
For original.
15 and a half.
Wait, the original was longer?!
Wait, really?!
It says the original was longer!
What?!
Bro!
I- they padded this chapter!
There's no way!
Oh, hey.
Can you come downstairs?
Come down.
Oh shit!
Okay!
I guess I'm fucking- won't be...
Did he come down yet?
I can't tell.
There you go.
Alright, nice.
We did it!
Yay!
Oh shit!
There was more.
Alright, it's fine.
That's fine.
I- maybe I should not have waste- guys, maybe I should not have wasted the ammo- the barrel there.
I didn't know there were like four more people coming in.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
That's fine.
Nice.
Wait, there's more of you?!
Get over here.
It's okay, I have a lot of pistol bullets.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No!
My loot!
My- what?
What did you say, Leo?
What do you want- Alright.
Oh!
Nice.
Oh shit!
Ah!
Shake!
Okay.
We're okay.
Oh my god.
It's alright.
I figured it out.
It's okay.
You really earned that stabbing.
Wait, where the fuck was he throwing at?
Maybe I should've just started shanking.
Maybe I should've upgraded the power.
What the fuck?
I clearly- Wait, what the fuck?
I clearly chose the wrong thing to upgrade.
Do you want me to shank you?
Do I- wait, there's more of you?!
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
I can shank you later.
Alright.
And she's burning.
That's good.
More loot for me.
That's good!
Doki the shanker.
This is what I've been waiting for.
Finally a game for me!
Okay.
I got back all the ammo too.
That's good too.
I got all my ammo back.
And the money!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Actually, the original needed two GameCube CDs because it was so heavy to store in one CD.
The game is stored in the CDs.
Jesus Christ.
No, I'm pretty sure- Like, I'm surprised that the original is longer than the remake.
I'm so surprised!
I felt like I like fucking got to Ashley already.
The original!
Wooo!
Shit!
This is worth it!
Alright.
Nice.
Good.
Wait, that's it?
I killed two!
Wooo!
Shit!
Shake!
Okay.
Nice.
We're good.
Holy shit, where are they coming from?
Where the fuck are these people coming from?
Did I get everything?
No, there's nothing.
There's a treasure somewhere.
Wait, I missed out on- Oh!
Oh!
Right here!
I see it.
How do I get it though?
Where the fuck do I get downstairs?
Uhhh...
Alright.
Where do I- Where the hell do I get downstairs?
Huh?
Oh, later!
Okay.
Later.
Alright.
I might get there later.
I've been thinking for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why doesn't Leon call stars for help?
Is he stupid?
Thank you for this- Look, this is his promotion, okay?
If he- If he can't protect the president's daughter, then what's the point?
He might as well fucking get fired.
He might as well go home, guys.
This is like- This is like his like- Job to get promoted.
Do you not want him to get promotion?
Where am I?
Like I'm just like, where am I all the time?
It's about pride!
Exactly!
If he comes back without the president's daughter, they're just gonna laugh at him!
They're gonna make fun of him!
Okay, let's go up.
He wants to show stars that he's not just a pretty boy!
That he's more than just th- What is this?
Oh no, not this guy.
Oh my gosh, it's a giant.
It's a giant.
That he's more than just the thighs.
Is there anyone who can destroy these blue medallions?
The air is polluted by their presence and I can't bear it.
Okay, query to the fish farm.
Okay.
Where are all- Where is all of them?
One- Jesus!
What the f- Okay, there's like three here, one here.
Alright.
Peta, thank you for the five!
Give the ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Is this what it takes to be promoted?
I'd rather be homeless.
Okay, look, they don't really have a lot.
That's right.
You ain't fucking- Oh shit, not the wolves!
There are more than just them?
Where are the other wolves?
It's okay.
Where is the good wolf!
Oh my god, this wolf is so fast!
I'd swear to god, okay.
Where's the good wolf!
I did my fucking good deed!
Nice money.
Can't believe it.
This game has taught me that good deeds mean nothing!
Means fucking nothing!
What are you saying?
Oh, that's true!
Wait, actually Bacon, that is so fucking true.
Wait, you're right.
He doesn't love his daughter enough!
You're right!
Bacon, if the president really wanted his daughter back, I'm sure he would have sent that more than one guy.
Oh no, that's where the troll is.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, that's the troll man.
I don't wanna pay no toll.
Oh, get up there.
That's right.
He wanted his daughter to never come back.
Oh my god.
This man.
This man knows what's up.
You're right, he would have sent two guys.
It was just... he knew Leon didn't have it in him.
Where is this?
Do I have to look up again?
Dude, I fucking knew it.
I always knew I had to look up.
Okay, there's a medallion here somewhere.
I'm looking.
Where the fuck is this medallion?
Wait, where is this medallion?
Wait!
It's up top?
Is it up there?
Always look up.
Up all the way there?
It's very high?
Okay, I don't have to care.
Thank god.
Go back to the yard?
It's outside?
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, there it is!
There it is.
There you go.
Dark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, currently recovering from... Oh god.
From any like type of teeth thing.
This fucking sucks.
Uh, pro tip, don't have bad gums.
Wait, can I open this?
No.
The surgery sucks.
Great stream.
So... fuck.
Holy shit.
That fucking sucks, bro.
Anything related to like teeth surgery stuff is... fucking sucks.
In general.
Oh, now I can climb.
Nice.
I need like one more snake.
Get over here.
Snake.
I mean, I'll take money.
Merchant?
There's your thing.
Is this where the merchant is?
Merchant?
That's your flame.
Is it not?
What are you selling?
Yeah.
Nice.
Wait, what's this?
Alright.
I'm gonna grab this.
Instead of letting your unused guns collect dust...
Why not sell them and spend the extra cash?
To upgrade a weapon you do use.
Okay.
Oh, I get almost all my money back.
Oh my god.
You're not gonna scam people?
You're better than regular merchants.
Alright, let me sell this.
A headdress with ra- Oh, this is where we put stones.
I don't think I have enough stones yet for this.
I need three- I need like one more ruby.
Uh...
I'm gonna sell you first.
I'm gonna sell you two.
And then I need to grab more guns.
Okay.
Uh...
Wait, can I- I cannot buy.
Oh!
Technically, I can trade for- I feel like I'm gonna wait until I find another ruby.
Uh...
More guns?
None of these guns are worth it though.
I don't think so.
None of these guns are worth it.
I'm gonna wait.
Do I- Upgrade the power of my knife?
Or shanky?
God damn it, Chris!
Chris!
Please hurry!
The bloodline is fading!
Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't- Okay, I will- I will save my money for now.
Where the fuck is the other typewriter?
Yeah.
Yes.
Wait, do I take the elevator?
Wait, what's the elevator?
Oh my god, there's so many things around me.
What's this?
Hexagon piece.
What's that for?
Oh, the church!
Oh my god, there's so many places.
Where do I go first?
Guys!
There's too many choices!
What is the elevator?
Minigame?
This?
That's a minigame?
Do I get anything?
Is this the mercenary?
Welcome, stranger.
Wait, I just gotcha!
Three or...
Is this your first time access?
What's this?
Destroy the pirates and shoot for the high score.
Are limited.
Each token based on the score for a chance to win.
Oh, that's easy!
Destroy several targets by shooting nearby diamonds.
Be careful when shooting a sailor.
Okay.
Some targets cannot be destroyed with one shot.
Shoot as many shots until they break.
Asserting conditions are met.
Bonus targets...
Oh, okay.
That sounds fun.
Alright.
We can do this.
Reward.
We'll do the pistol first.
Okay.
100% obtained.
At least 7000.
At least...
What do the pirates and the sailors look like though?
Okay.
We can do this.
Okay, we know...
Oh, shit!
I didn't see the fucking...
Okay.
Reloading.
Oh, God.
I hate this.
I'm so anxious.
Does it matter if it's a headshot?
Oh, it matters if there's a skull.
I'm fucking up!
Reloading!
No!
I'm fucking...
I fucked up!
I got... No!
Okay, okay, okay, I understand now.
I understand.
I was... I understand now.
Okay.
Guys, I figured it out.
Okay, there we go.
Reload.
Reloading.
Okay.
There's like a... There's like a need.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get over here.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
What's the bonus time?
There's falloff!
Okay, 4 out of 6.
Okay, nice.
Gold token.
Nice.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
Okay.
100%!
Okay, we're gonna get that 100%.
Okay.
We're gonna get that 100%.
We can do this.
Oh god.
That was close.
That was a thing close.
Oh god.
No!
I can't believe I fucked up!
I already ruined it.
It's already gone!
No!
We were so close!
Okay, this time.
This time.
I figured it out.
I'm in the groove.
I'm in the groove now.
Oh god.
That was close.
I'm in the groove.
I'm in the groove!
Oh god.
No.
No!
No no no no no no no!
Please!
Oh.
Don't rush it!
Don't you- Don't rush it!
You don't need to rush!
Come on.
No!
Oh!
Okay.
Come on.
No!
I give up.
I wanted to try the other one.
Oh my god.
This is so sad.
Someone please.
Play the saddest violin.
The saddest violin.
It truly is the saddest thing.
Oh, I can collide?
Bro, what?
I didn't know I can collide this.
Oh, fuck!
I didn't see it!
I didn't see the fucking skull.
Oh no, are you ser- NO!
ARE YOU SERIOUS?!
There's 10?
Where the fuck was the others?
I guess like the bonus ones, right?
Okay, wait wait.
This one I can do.
I didn't realize there was a collide.
Okay.
We don't need the fucking- We don't need a zoom in!
We don't need a zoom in guys!
It's so close!
We already have the scope!
Okay.
Whoop!
Collat!
Okay.
Whoop!
Collat!
Alright.
Alright, we figured this out.
Come on.
Okay.
I gotta make sure he doesn't have a fucking skull on him.
No no no.
Yes!
No!
That was a hit!
That was a fucking hit!
I swear that was a hit!
That was 100% a hit.
God damn it.
That was 100% a hit, man.
This is...
I hate this.
I hate it here.
I...
What?
Oh, it's over here.
I couldn't see him.
Oh.
I hate it here.
I can't believe it.
My trigger finger.
I'm getting old.
Alright, I'm too lazy to grab the...
I'm too lazy to grab the sniper.
Unless...
Boom!
What the...
No!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, sailor!
Alright, that was not my best...
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done.
That was not my best one.
Um...
A gold can exchange all the shooting...
Can I do this?
What do I get?
Yay!
What is this?
I got 40% off resources.
Oh!
That's nice.
Okay.
What do I get from this?
I got 40% off resources.
20% magnum ammo craft bonus frequencies.
I like that!
What is this?
That's yellow!
40% ammo resell value.
Wait, what does that mean?
I don't know how to put the charms on.
Okay, but how do I put it on?
I didn't like...
Do I...
How do I put that on?
It just on me this entire time?
Do I...
Oh, sell...
Sell ammo.
Typewriter!
Oh, okay.
Alright, we'll go to the typewriter.
Hmm.
Alright, nice.
Thank you, backseaters.
Oh!
Customize.
Wait, can I only put one?
Equip left.
Oh, I can equip everything!
Look at them!
Look at...
I don't remember what they were, but look at them!
What were they?
Can I...
Can I see what they are?
Oh, there we go.
It's there.
Nevermind.
40% off resources.
40%... Okay, there we go.
We figured it out.
Now we're gaming.
Yeah, I figured it out.
I was like, what were they again?
Okay.
Let's see.
10,000...
We don't need to upgrade anything yet, so we can just chill.
We can chill for now.
Do we go downstairs or through the door?
I think through the door is the troll.
Backseater save the...
Oh, wait, did I just save?
I don't remember what I saved.
I'm gonna save again.
Repair a knife?
Oh, shit.
Did I not repair it?
Tune up.
Let's see.
It's alright.
It has a lot of HP.
Alright.
Do we go downstairs?
Or through the door?
I hear very conflicting answers, so I went downstairs.
Okay.
Shoot the lake?
Okay, guys.
This is it.
I can shoot this.
Are we here?
Oh, not this lake?
God damn it.
Wrong lake.
I am just listening to what you guys are telling me, guys.
Wait, but then what's through the door?
Oh, wait.
This is just loot.
Nice.
That's good.
It's just loot.
What the fuck?
What's that sound?
Is there any more loot in there?
Loot?
No more loot.
Guys, one day we'll get to the right lake, guys.
It's just not today.
We just haven't made it to the right lake.
Collectible?
Oh, I didn't even hear that.
Guys, there's so...
Oh, that's the sound I was hearing!
I was like wondering what that sound was.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, how did I miss?
There he is.
That's what it was.
It was just a loot detour.
Yeah.
I got my tangerines!
Let's go!
Alright.
Is it time to fight?
Okay, fine.
Fine!
I'll repair it.
I have enough money.
Alright, guys.
It's time!
It's troll time!
I need to make sure I reload everything.
I need to make sure everything is reloaded.
Okay, let me see.
Do I have... Oh, I have enough to craft.
Okay, nice.
Okay, craft.
Rifle.
You need a rifle anyway.
Okay.
Put that here.
Do I have enough to craft another one?
It's time.
It's craft time.
Here we go.
It's time for the troll!
Wait, is it?
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Oh, it's this way.
Whoops.
Sorry.
Sorry, it was this way.
Never mind!
It's not troll time!
It's fish time!
Fish this early?
Hello.
Oh, it is!
When will I meet my bro again?
Wait, who is he throwing?
Wait, is that the...
Wait, who?
Who is he?
Oh, it's the first cop!
Where's our friend?
That's our best friend.
Is that loot?
Okay, loot.
Loot.
Oh my god, look at all this loot.
That I'm definitely not gonna...
Wait, can I shoot the loot here?
This is a good use of my rifle ammo.
I feel like...
Wait, will I be able to shoot the loot?
Shoot it.
It's not...
It was not worth it, guys.
The rifle ammo takes a while.
Guys, guys.
It was one rifle...
Wait, for 1k?
Oh my god, it's worth it!
Holy shit!
Okay.
Okay, 1k.
Yo, bro, it's worth it, guys.
Okay.
Oh my god!
It's okay!
It's so worth it!
Where's the other one?
This is so worth it.
Where are the others?
Wait, hope I can get those later.
Bro, wait, can I get this later?
Did I just waste my money?
I just...
Bro, one bullet is practically 1k.
Not gonna lie.
That's a shit note.
Oh, I get them for... whoops!
Whoops, that's awkward.
That's fucking awkward.
I thought it was never gonna be free.
Whoopsie.
Oh well.
It's good to know now!
The boat fuel is stored with the generator fuel inside the processing building at the fish farm.
Take only what you need.
Dab.
Well, it's good to know now.
I know now, guys.
What's this?
Is this a puzzle?
Oh, I need to find more.
Alright.
Is this the lake, guys?
Did we find the lake?
Did we finally make...
Oh wait, there's some...
Where is it?
There's one here.
Where the fuck is that blue medallion?
There's a blue medallion here somewhere.
Oh, I'm not looking at it.
The right direction?
Question mark?
Is it in here?
Okay, I'm not gonna do it.
Do it now because I feel like...
Alright, we're gonna shoot the lake.
Hello.
Just like old times.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, what?
Oh!
Okay.
Just like old times.
Yeah!
I did the whole thing again!
When did I save?
Did I do this?
Guys, I don't remember when I last saved.
When was my last save?
When?
Okay, I have to do this.
I have to do this again.
I don't remember.
Now I have to do this again.
Oh my god.
Boop.
I thought they would autosave me earlier.
But I was wrong.
The autosave was not that.
It was not there.
I already shoot him?
I already did.
Oh my god.
Did I repair my knife?
Okay, well, no.
But if I repaired my knife...
Okay, wait.
Let's see.
Did I repair it?
I didn't.
Oh god.
Okay, let's...
Okay, I customized the case.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Okay.
I customized the case.
That's good.
We're okay.
Case has been customized.
I don't have to worry about that.
Alright.
I already have it.
I already have everything.
Alright.
Back here we go.
It's time to look at the fish again.
It's okay.
I saved my rifle ammo.
We can watch this again.
Our friend.
Yeah, we didn't waste any ammo, guys.
That's the best part.
We did it.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Wait, I can skip?
Oh, I can skip.
No, we won't watch this again.
Yay.
Goodbye, fish.
Goodbye.
Yeah, that was my first death because of the fucking fish.
Where's the castle?
It's almost like look at the castle.
Oh, I can.
Damn.
He's like Lord Farquaad.
He's compensating.
Oh yeah, he's just...
He's as short as him too.
He is just like Lord Farquaad.
I'm not gonna shoot the water.
We've already established the water.
Gotta get the money.
The money.
Alright, let's put this guy in.
We need like two more.
Uh...
Hello.
Arrows.
Nice.
Got our loot.
And some herbs.
And another kitchen knife.
Good old kitchen knife.
I'm not gonna...
Guys, I'm not looting this again.
Can't make me loot this again.
Wait, is there an egg in here?
Oh, ammo.
That's even better than an egg.
Ammo.
That's even better.
And I saved my two rifle ammo from earlier.
Alright, we're not gonna...
We're not gonna shoot the lake again.
Uh... Oh yeah.
Wait, we need to figure out where the medallion is.
Guys, where is the medallion?
It's like...
Somewhere here.
It's not...
Up above?
Wait, where is the medallion?
Under?
Here?
I don't see it.
Wait, where is it?
Where the fuck is the medallion?
Guys, I don't know.
Let's go back.
I don't feel so good.
Oh, there it is.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I got scared.
I actually got scared.
I don't know.
I don't really want to go back there, guys.
There's like something above.
Like here?
There's something back there.
Do I go back there?
Or...
I don't know if I should go back here.
I'm worried this is gonna advance the...
Okay, this is gonna advance stuff.
There's the bed.
Oh, do I click the boat?
Yeah, check the boat.
I'm gonna check the boat.
It's like there was a boat there too.
I swear to god.
If the fucking fish eats me while I look at the boat.
I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Oh, it's the gas thing.
It's the gas mission.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I swear to god.
If I check the boat and the fish comes out.
I swear to fucking god.
I'm not gonna...
I shot the lake.
I already shot the lake.
I'm not doing that again.
Alright.
Hello?
No!
Oh, oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
The fish can't be here.
It's too fucking...
It's not deep enough.
Oh, wait a minute.
It's him again.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that scared me.
I thought like I got shot at.
I thought I got shot at myself.
Okay.
Woo!
Granny, get out of here.
Oh, granny, please.
Get st...
Oh, I can't get there in time.
I can't get there in time.
Granny!
Oh, oh, wait.
Wait, he's pretty big.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, he's gonna turn, but I don't have time.
I don't have time.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that hit her head.
That was not what I wanted to do, but that's fine.
Jesus Christ, that took so long.
Alright.
That's okay.
It's okay.
I still lived.
That scared the shit out of me, but I still lived.
It hit her head, but it still worked.
Okay?
It still worked.
That's all that mattered.
The fucking ricochet there.
Wait, what?
I heard a snake.
That's fucking right.
You can't get away from me.
I need that money.
Okay, hand grenade.
I think that...
That was such a waste of a grenade.
I did not need to fucking do that.
Okay, high ground.
Okay.
We'll take the high ground.
I'm already lost, by the way.
I am...
Did I come from here?
I came from here, right?
No, I did not.
Wait a minute.
Whoa!
What's that sound?
Arrows?
Someone...
shot an arrow?
I don't see anybody.
Am I safe?
I think I'm good.
Right?
Down I go.
We need our map emote back.
I'll just photoshop a map on top of my dog.
Wait, wait!
There is an arrow!
I'm a better sniper than you though.
There you go.
Headshot.
That's right.
I don't need no flames.
Okay.
Is there anything I'm missing?
There's one more medallion here.
I'm gonna make sure I kill everybody first.
Wait, where's that?
Oh, there he is.
Wrong way, sucker.
Loser.
Wrong way.
Come on.
That's sucking right.
Please don't turn.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
Easy.
Oh, oh!
There you go.
Wait, you're still alive?
Oh, wait, wait, wait!
I heard beep, beep, beep, beep!
Oh, shit!
Head!
I heard beeps!
Woo!
Oh, shit!
No!
I think the one!
Oh, shit!
Oh, there's so many of you!
Oh, god!
Oh, shit!
My kitchen knife!
Kitchen knife!
Please!
Oh, my god.
There.
Ah!
Shit!
Kitchen knife!
Whoop.
Okay.
Oh, my god!
That was worth it!
There you go.
It was so worth it.
Wait.
Oh, no.
He's dead.
Alright.
We're fine.
You saw the parries, though?
Dude!
That parry, though!
That was some sick parry!
Alright.
Let's see.
We gotta...
We can eat our eggs now.
You know, we can...
We can eat our... Look!
See!
Look at that!
Nothing to worry about!
We ate our eggs.
Guys!
So calm!
Where is that?
Where the fuck?
Oh, the beeping was here.
Okay.
I almost ran into that.
Thank god.
Thank god I heard the beeps in time.
Okay.
Barrel.
Nice.
Oh!
More money!
That's what I like.
Okay.
There's a treasure here.
There's like two more medallions.
Where could they be?
Woop!
Where could the medallions be?
I think I hate finding the medallions the most!
They're so fucking...
Oh my god.
They're so annoying.
Yeah!
Pipe!
Fuck.
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
Where do I go?
This way?
Loot!
Love me my loot!
Fish!
Oh.
What?
Can I sell this?
Oh!
I can eat it!
Oh, there it is!
Nice.
Okay.
One more.
We need one more medallion.
It's like over here?
Over here?
Oh!
Thank god!
Okay.
That was close.
That was so fucking close.
Where's the last one?
It's like here somewhere?
Who said that?
What?
Where's the medallion?
Where is it?
Like...
I'm like on it.
We already have three snakes.
Where?
Medallion?
Oh, is it below?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna get that barrel first and I'll go below.
Below me.
Not here.
So it's on the other side.
Alright, we're gonna grab this barrel and then we'll...
We'll head over.
Nice.
Wait, how do I get that?
It's important.
Can I make this?
I can make this.
Okay.
Alright, Leon.
Sorry.
Leon, even though...
Leon's thighs are thick as fuck...
They can't be jumping.
They're not for jumping, clearly.
Those thighs were not meant to be doing any jumping.
Where do I get the other side?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Another hexagon piece.
Here's something on the other side that dropped.
There's the snake.
You know what?
Extra money.
That's right.
You ain't...
You didn't pay your loans, crow.
That's fucking right.
Hahaha.
Don't think I forgot about you.
Let me in!
Gotta make sure nobody else is here.
Yeah, that's right.
Don't think I forgot.
Oh, another egg.
Oh, there's the spiel.
That's what we needed.
Yeah.
There can only be one bird.
Hahaha.
There can only be one bird in this game.
That's fucking right.
You didn't pay your rent.
All birds have to pay rent to Doki Bird.
I trademarked bird.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I did it.
I trademarked bird.
You all have to pay for the trademark now.
Let's see.
Craft.
I think I always need shotgun ammo.
Not gonna lie.
I should have craft rifle ammo.
And then I'll craft other stuff later.
Oh!
Whoa!
I almost got baited.
Holy shit.
I almost got baited by the money.
The bird tax.
That was so close.
Wait.
Oh, I can stay on high ground.
That's okay.
I can stay on high ground.
That's fucking right.
They can't get me.
Where's the others?
Where are they?
Oh shit!
She has a... Oh fuck!
What?
Oh fuck!
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh no.
Okay.
I don't have to stab.
What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
How did she get there that fast?
You kill them all?
Nice.
I'm not bird bite playing them.
Guess I have to pay for them since I can't.
Thank you for the super channeling.
Thank you.
Ella?
Wait.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Whoops.
Nice.
I need to shank you.
Oh, got back my ammo too.
Don't you love it when you get back your ammo?
Nice.
And gunpowder.
That's everything.
Money.
Where's that money?
Where's that?
Nice.
Almost missed out on the money.
All these people late for the party.
We had a set schedule, sir.
Up we go.
Do I need to save before I fight the fish?
I swear to god.
If I die, I'll have to do this part all over again.
I swear to fuck.
I need to know right now, guys.
Do I need to save before I fight this fucking fish?
Yes?
Okay, I'm going back.
All right, fish.
Give me a sec.
I'm going back to the merchant.
I might as well.
I have so much stuff to sell anyway.
All right.
Intermission time.
Be right back, fish.
I'm going to the merchant.
Okay.
Nice.
Got this.
Can I trade for anything better now?
Not yet.
Okay.
Let's see.
Antique pipe.
Okay, we can sell that now.
We can sell these two.
And then we can sell our vipers.
Ooh, we have so much money.
Yay!
Okay.
What should we do with our money right now?
The laser sight keeps your pistol at full charge all the time?
Wait, that's so good!
I don't want... they don't have it.
Never mind.
That's so good!
But they don't have it.
Fine, I'll repair the knife.
Trade.
Oh, it's on the trade?
Oh, wait, do I have enough?
Is it worth it?
Trade.
Is it worth it, guys?
Or should I save?
Do I do it or save money?
Yeah?
Okay, we're getting it.
Alright.
What should we upgrade?
Should we upgrade the shotgun?
Guys?
Should we upgrade the power?
Is it worth it?
Is that worth it?
Nope.
Okay, that's one guy.
So I'm...
The one guy I'm not gonna listen to.
And I'll save the rest.
Alright.
Here we go.
He's like...
He's not gonna be the only one, guy!
I'm coming in too!
Let me make sure I reload everything.
Alright.
I should have enough.
Okay, let's see.
Uh... I'm just gonna eat this egg right now and be full HP.
There's no point.
Okay, and then...
Parts.
Put that on my pistol.
I'm gonna put my fucking kitchen knife in here.
Yeah!
Bum-ba-da-dum-ba-da-dum Bum-ba-da-dum-ba-da-dum Bum-ba-da-dum-ba-da-dum Alright.
Here we go.
Fish time!
Got my fucking rifle!
Oh wait.
Forgot the puzzle.
Forgot the puzzle!
Puzzle!
Alright.
I'm a keeper for food.
What if I need it?
Wait, can I do the puzzle now?
No?
Oh, I need one more then.
I'm not gonna shoot the fish!
I already shot the fish!
I'm not shooting the fish!
We already shot the fish!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Back into the lake.
I forgot how this boss fight goes.
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I'm gonna die here.
I already forgot.
I remember I was so confused when we did this.
Yeah, it's equipped.
I equipped it instantly.
I just remember being so fucking confused I just remember being so fucking confused doing this boss fight.
Stab the water!
It's so easy, Doki!
Just fucking shake the water!
Shake the fish!
OH SHIT!
I'M SORRY!
I didn't mean it!
How do I play this?
Shake it!
Wait, what?
Stab the fish?
Stab the fish!
Oh my god!
It is shake the fish!
Shake the fish!
We're doing it!
We're shaking the fish!
I knew it!
I knew we were gonna shake the fish.
I fucking knew it.
Alright.
Where the fuck is he?
Nice.
Wait, let me get my thousand dollars.
This is important!
Wait, what?
Think you can swallow me whole, huh?
Oh!
What?
Oh wait, that doesn't count.
Got my thousand!
Oh shit!
What?
That was a headshot!
That's bullshit!
Oh wait, whoops.
That was bullshit.
That was 100% a headshot.
Right there.
That was fucking bullshit!
So check the bots!
Check the fucking bots!
Alright, where is he gonna go?
Alright, come on.
Come on.
Come on, I know you wanna come over.
I'm waiting.
Where'd you go?
What?
Oh!
Oh, I have
a plan!
Alright, we're so fucking dead.
I got confused.
Woo!
We're so fucked.
We're so fucked, guys.
Guys.
I got confused.
I got a little bit confused.
Phew!
It's okay.
I wish I know what his HP is though.
I really wish I know how fucking low this fish is.
It's here!
Guys, GG's.
GG's!
GG's, guys.
We had a good run!
No!
Wait!
What?
Oh no.
Guys, it's okay.
We got 20k though!
It was a good run.
It was such a good run.
Oh my god.
This fucking fight.
Man.
Wait, we did it!
1 HP!
Oh, please.
No way.
First try.
We did it, guys.
We shanked the fish.
1 HP in our dream.
How does she do it?
How does she always kill the fish?
She kills the bosses with 1 HP.
Oh, jeez.
That's a lot of blood.
Actually, first try.
Yay!
Nice.
We did pretty good.
85% accuracy.
That's pretty good.
That's pretty good, guys.
Alright, save.
Here we go.
We're in London now, motherfucker.
Leon's body is the most sacred body?
That's why he's going to continue to bloodline.
Oh god.
The parasite.
I'm sadly...
Just teaching him about the birds and the bees...
It's okay, I have my rifle.
It's okay, I'll just shoot it with my rifle.
Still no Ashley.
Still no Ash- It's okay, you know what?
I'm happy.
I don't really want to see Ashley right now.
Just trying to see if I can see any barrels from here.
Alright, whoop!
Nice handgun.
Wait, where- What the fuck, where are we?
Find the key to the church- Oh, I'm like all the way here!
Hey, there's somebody's hat!
Nice hat!
Hey, that's like my hat!
Do I look at this guy's face again?
Is there anything in here?
Oh, resources!
Oh no, that's just the Holy Mary.
Is there a ladder?
No, no ladder.
Hello, everybody!
Oh, it's night time?
Oh, I do not like this.
Alright guys, we're gonna call it here!
Okay, I think this is a good time to call it.
After seeing it being night time.
Yeah!
I was like y'know what?
No, no this is a good time to call it there.
We did four hours.
We got a boss, but let's just, we'll do the other chapter another time...
There's like, night time.
Oh, it's like, oh, it's the horror part of the horror game.
I'm good, I'm good.
That's okay.
I think that's a good time to stop now.
Brother, thank you for the aca aca aca sopa!
Thank you!
Well guys, I hope you guys had a great time for part one!
Everybody, I had a great time playing today.
It's great to play Resident Evil 4 again, playing the remake for the first time.
Definitely enjoyed it a lot so far.
I really enjoyed the game so far.
The controls are less... you know, since it's a newer game, the controls are definitely less scuffed.
It's definitely easier to control compared to the OG Resident Evil 4.
So that's what I like the most.
But yeah!
I had a great time!
I hope you guys...
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I hope you guys enjoyed it too.
Everybody...
I think I read a lot of super chats coming in so there wasn't really much to catch up on.
So I'm gonna call it here because we did do a very long stream today.
Also Mr. Mad messaged me and was like, Oh hey, are you free today?
I was like, I'm streaming.
Mr. Mad messaged me in the middle of my stream and was like, Hey, are you free right now?
I was like, no, I'm streaming.
And he was like, oh okay, after the stream we usually...
I wanted to tell you something about something.
And I was like, alright!
Alright, anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Tomorrow is a rest day for me.
I usually take Sundays off.
So like usually...
Unless there's like an event or a tournament or something on Sunday.
But majority of the time, Sunday is my off day.
So don't worry if you're like, Oh my god, what is your schedule with me for tomorrow?
Sunday usually is my rest day.
Anyway everybody!
I had a great time playing part 1.
Definitely gonna be doing part 2 of Resident Evil 4.
I might make a long session for part 2.
Because it is a 15 hour game.
So I might do a...
A longer session than usual for Resident Evil 4.
For Resident Evil 4 part 2.
So I might start at like 12.30 or something.
PM, PST.
When I do long sessions.
But anyway guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!
Thanks for watching!